I can swap, I swap.
Sorry, I was like, I was trying to... I was like, pause intro because I was trying to find the scene for it.
So like, okay, guys, if like, the positioning-wise and sizes are different from part one, it's because I forgot we were doing a part two, so I didn't save any of the settings of it.
And so none of the settings were saved.
That's our Toki book!
And also, I might need sound balancing for the game again, because I also did not save the sound balancing.
Whoopsie.
Wait, oh no, what happened to your ear?
Oh my...
It's like a unicorn.
I'm fixing it.
Wait, what do you mean it's like a unicorn?
It's like, it was in the center of your head.
So it was like a unicorn.
I don't know why it does what it does.
Just let it happen.
Sorry, we were just a little bit late because we were gossiping.
You know, girls just being girls.
Hee hee.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, we were talking about clothes.
Yeah, we were talking about clothes and factories and where to get cheap Louis Vuitton bags.
Yeah.
We were like...
Oh yeah.
And then we were also talking about the Minecraft movie.
So Min hasn't seen the Minecraft movie yet.
Even though she was like, I'm going to watch it the day it releases.
Well, thank God I didn't because...
We were throwing popcorn.
Yeah, because like, we were like...
Because like, booze were thinking about watching the Minecraft movie when it got released.
But then people started throwing popcorn and drinks at others.
And eggs.
Did you hear how they were chucking eggs at people too?
I saw someone bring a live chicken.
Yeah, no.
I talked about it on stream.
But the guy who brought...
Because he's like a fucking influencer on TikTok or some shit.
And then he just left the chicken like on somebody's doorstep.
He just like abandoned it.
And then someone was like, what the fuck?
Why did you...
And he streamed...
Like he recorded himself abandoning the chicken.
And then people were like...
Were like, what the fuck?
Why did you do that?
And then he was like...
And then he replied with...
We...
Was it...
Like X amount of chickens are killed every day.
So you could eat them.
Oh my God.
Wow.
So like...
One chicken life does not matter that much.
Like I was just like...
What the fuck?
Like what kind of...
Oh my God.
I'm just like...
Like what kind of...
What kind of person are you?
Like...
I wish I could throw him in lava in Minecraft.
Yeah.
In Minecraft, guys.
In Minecraft.
Yeah.
I'm not going to fly him all the way to like...
One of the active volcanoes in Scandinavia.
And then chuck him in there.
Oh.
Wait.
We can get closer.
Hawaii.
Oh, that's true.
We can just chuck him in Hawaii.
Yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
Sacrifice.
In Minecraft though.
In Hawaii Minecraft.
Yeah.
It's all legal if it's in Minecraft.
Oh boy, Doki.
Are you excited for today?
Okay.
Let me...
Let me open this real quick.
Okay.
Let me...
I thought you meant the game.
Okay.
Now I'm ready.
Oh my god.
All it took was one sip, you guys.
She's such a lightweight.
She's tipsy already.
I got one sip in me.
I'm ready now.
It wasn't even that bad last time.
Oh, you're not the one playing.
As the spectator watching, it wasn't even that bad.
I don't even have to be here.
I wasn't even...
Oh yeah, I remember when...
What was it?
The mortary...
This is not my charity.
The mortary assistant or whatever.
I'm like, it wasn't that bad.
That was the same.
The mortuary.
Yeah.
Yeah, you remember that?
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry, man.
It wasn't that bad.
Oh, you saw that guy outside the window?
What are you, a fucking pussy?
Is this...
Payback for the mortuary?
Yes, I can hold a grudge for a very long time.
Oh, I know.
Happy one year anniversary to the mortuary assistant.
No, it wasn't one year.
Happy two year anniversary.
Yeah, I think it's been longer than that.
Wow, happy anniversary, everybody.
I can wait.
A bird never forgets.
What are you, an elephant?
There's literally a bird brain because birds forget.
This is the one thing I remember.
I have storage for five things, and this is one out of the five.
I waited.
I was like, counting my days till I get my turn.
Oh, I guess if you count crows, yeah.
That's true.
Crows are very vindictive.
No, that's true.
They can hold grudges for a very long time.
You hear, like, there's, like, there were people, like, scaring, like, a kid, like, that was scaring a group of crows.
And then, like, ever since they did that, like, the crows followed him where he works or something.
And then just started shitting on his car every day.
Is it crows?
Wait, what's the ones that imitate human voices?
Parrots?
No, no.
No, ravens.
Is it raven?
Or corvids?
Yeah, corvids.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, they can imitate voices.
No, they're pretty smart, too.
They're, like, but the thing is, they're as smart as, like, a six-year-old or four.
So, like, they're not that smart, you think about it.
I won't trust a six-year-old with anything.
They're smart enough to see shiny thing and then bring you something.
That's true.
Yeah, there was, like, I read a story of, like, this little girl that, like, fed crows every day.
And then, like, they just bring her money.
Yeah, yeah.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, because of coins and stuff.
So if they see a shiny coin, they just give it to you.
So she has a collection of shiny things, and some of them was just money.
So you can have an army of the bird ticeth and the bird giveth.
You can train a group of crows to just get rich.
Get like 30 crows and just feed them every day.
Actually, I'm wondering, a birdseater is cheap.
Birdseater is really cheap.
Yeah, I think so.
As long as you don't feed them bread.
By the way, don't feed birds bread, because they can actually explode.
Oh, you know what?
What happened to Doki, then?
If you feed me bread, I'll fucking pop!
Some people might be excited about that.
Because it, like, expands their, like, gut-slash-heart or something, and then they can actually, like, explode or something.
I thought that was just rice.
Is it also bread?
Yeah, it's also bread.
Bread is also not healthy for birds.
And also, did you read... I saw this on Twitter, but there was this, like, not article, this Reddit post about how this girl's hamster accidentally got into, like, baking soda, and then she ate...
Like, the hamster ate...
No!
Wait, let me find that.
I was like, what?
Why are you finding... Don't find me!
No, it's not visual!
It's not visual, I said it, but I read it.
Oh, yeah, it's like, my hamster exploded.
So, I've been crying in my room for two hours now.
I was making some salad dressing in the kitchen with my pet hamster.
My sister and friends were also doing something.
I spilled a bottle of vinegar, so I left to get a towel.
And then when I came back, Manny was drinking it.
I didn't think anything of it, so I let him help me clean it up.
All of a sudden, Manny starts acting really weird.
He's normally very full of energy, but he's just sitting still.
Everyone gathered around him, trying to figure out what was wrong.
Suddenly, we hear a fizzling noise coming from inside Manny, and he started expanding.
He let out a final squeak and bursted.
Bubbles and blood went everywhere.
My sister and her friends started screaming and crying.
Irene got my dad and he cleaned it up.
We looked in the pantry, and apparently, Manny got into the baking soda and ate a bunch of it.
He said, I think I'm traumatized now.
Why'd you read it?
I think I'm traumatized now.
What is...
Don't people say, like, hamsters die in the most violent ways always for some reason?
Mine...
My sister had one, and it got washed away in a flood.
Oh my god, is he okay?
Do you think he's okay, guys?
Probably.
He's fine.
He, like, washed to Miami.
Yeah, he went to Florida.
He's, like, went to the deep, like, probably South America.
He's, like, living his best life.
Yeah, he's enjoying his life there right now.
He's probably fine.
He found a wife in...
He found a wife.
They had kids.
They started a family in, like, Brazil or something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I had a friend who had a pet hamster, and it was pregnant.
And then the mom...
You know how, like, rodents eat their kids if they're stretched too much?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so then the mom ate all the kids except for one.
Because, like, my friend stopped it in time.
But then she...
The mom, like, ate half of its leg.
Before, like, they stopped it.
See, that's traumatizing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's more traumatizing.
So I'm just saying, like, don't stress me out.
Or bye-bye, men.
Don't worry.
Some people are into that.
That's what, vore?
That's what vore is.
I think someone...
I think you have to be into the vore to be vore.
No, like...
I mean, like...
I mean, people who watch can be into it.
No, I thought...
I think it's the appeal is the people want to experience it, no?
No, I thought, like...
I thought it was just, like, people just...
Well, there's, like, the person who eats the person that likes it.
Because they just want to feel...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I don't remember if I've ever...
It's because they want to feel like they're a baby again.
No, okay.
Okay, this is, like, really fucked up.
But, like, one of my friends sent me this.
I don't know if I've ever talked about it on stream.
Or, like, if I ever talked about it in my previous channel.
But one of my friends sent this to me as, like, a joke.
But there's, like...
You know how, like, vore is, like, a specific hink, right?
So, like, people can have replicated that experience.
Like, I got sent to this, like...
You mean, like, what the fuck?
I was, like...
And then I, like, looked into it.
Because I was, like, what the fuck?
Because, like, it's their entire account.
It was a Twitter account.
And it was basically, like...
This...
It was, like, this inflated belly suit thing.
And then they put someone inside the belly.
And then you see, like, hands poked, like, just trying to...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Do you wanna lick?
Do you wanna see what...
No, I'm fine.
I'm...
My eyes are pure.
Your eyes are not pure.
Don't fuck with me.
You've seen many things.
That's what I'm here for.
If you share it with me, you have to share it with the class.
Okay.
Don't share it with me.
How do you have the link on hand?
No, I don't have it.
I'm searching it up.
I know exactly what it looks like because it's been...
If I was sent this, everyone has to see it.
I don't have to click it.
I had to... I was sent...
Oh no, she found it.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's just as fucked up as I remembered.
It's...
It's just...
It's so sad.
It's so sad that I don't want it now.
I don't want it now.
You think I wanted it when I first saw it?
You can stop the cycle.
No, I will continue the cycle.
I will continue it.
It's like...
I bet you won't retweet it.
No, I won't.
I will not retweet it.
That's a reminder.
I mean, you can...
Feel free to retweet it.
No, it's your account.
Feel free.
It's your account.
Yeah.
It's a video.
Oh my god.
It's a video!
I can just see the...
I can...
So I have, like, my window, like a...
Firefox window half covering Discord.
Yeah.
So I, like, just see a preview of, like, the little furry face sticking out.
I don't want this!
Why?
I don't want that!
Did you post it in the chat?
You can post in the chat if you want to.
No, you have to.
It's yours.
What do you say about stop the cycle?
Oh, so you want me to continue...
I'm not having this.
So you want me to continue the cycle.
You're like, you can stop the cycle.
I'm stopping the cycle from here.
After sending it to Mint, I need to stop this.
It's like a cursed link if you don't send this to five people.
Yeah, send this to five people or you'll be in that stomach.
Do you want to stop the cycle, Mint?
I don't think I can post links in your chat, I'm on a mod.
Don't worry, I'll mod you so you can stop.
Oh, really?
Alright, let me just try something in chat, Mint.
Do you want your mod?
We can stop the cycle, but I don't think... Here, let me try.
I'm not even gonna... I'm not gonna... I'm not looking at this.
I'm not even looking at... Oh my god, it's so horrible.
Just the preview is so...
No!
Wait, I don't want this.
I don't want people to be like, look at the thing Mint posted.
It's from you.
I'm not watching this.
I'm not doing this.
You can see... You can see the person in there, right?
You can see them trying to get out, right?
I think I see what looks like knees.
That's what I was saying.
It's like... You can be the person who eats the guy or the guy in the stomach.
You can do whatever I know.
You know, if you don't... If you don't finish Visage, you're gonna go into that stomach.
You have to... You have to... You have to... Are you gonna be... Are you against your stomach?
No!
It's gonna be this guy.
It's gonna be... This guy, the specific random guy.
Yeah!
If you don't finish Visage, you'll get into this man's stomach.
You have to finish... You have to finish the game.
Or you'll get bored.
You know what?
Wait, I can see his foot.
Like, it's a...
Why are you watching it?
I don't consent to watching this person's game.
God damn.
You said it was fictional.
I'm here to prove you wrong.
You can...
I should... I could... I should never doubt...
Never... Never doubt my knowledge.
Not... Not just your knowledge, but the strength of... of... perversion.
The lengths people will go to.
Oh my God.
I forgot... I forgot to, like, unbind my reposition button.
Okay, give me a sec.
Oh, oops.
Whoopsie.
Let me... I need... I realized that, like, I didn't lock my position too.
Give me a sec.
I need... Sorry, I was too... I was too busy with showing Mint something very important.
Her secret stash.
She found it so quickly, you guys.
You guys want... You want to know what I Googled?
You...
You Googled it!
You had to Google it!
I had to Google image this.
I had to Google it!
I had to Google...
I had to Google image to find exactly what I was explaining to you.
I...
Nah, yeah, she had it bookmarked.
She definitely had it bookmarked.
Alright, locked.
I don't care about immersion right now.
We just...
We don't care about immersion.
We saw things.
What are you doing?
Immersion.
Oops.
No immersion.
Whoop, nobody saw that again.
Nobody saw that.
Whoop.
Nobody saw.
Yep, everything's fine.
Everything's fine.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
What was that?
I want to explain more about something before we started.
I was like, oh, I'll explain more later, but I forgot what it was.
We have... we jumped through, like, so many topics that...
I'm exhausted right now.
Alright, let me finally boot up the game.
Sound guy, I hope you're still around.
Oh, yeah, have you ever... remember when, like, um, what was it?
Was it Snuffy or Daimu that was asking us to try out Schedule 1?
Do you remember that?
Oh, I think it was Laimla.
Yeah, yeah.
So, like, originally, like, we were sort of, like, bringing up the idea of playing Schedule 1 together as sloppy sisters, but then, like, I think all of us just got busy.
Yeah.
Yeah, we all just got busy, so we never, like, had that.
But I played Schedule 1 a couple of days ago with some friends.
Um, it's very addicting, let's just say.
Is it?
It's, like, um, it's a simulator, right?
So, like, it's, like, so you do something over and over again, and it's incredibly addicting.
Just, like, making drugs.
So, just...
What?
Is it better with... Wait, did you play it multiplayer?
Yeah, it's better... If you do single player, you can actually, like, get so overwhelmed.
So, like, even when I had, like, two other people playing with me, like, it was so much work and everything.
Um, but, like, I don't know if I could ever play this, like, on stream, because I get, like, so absorbed into it.
Like, I would be like, okay, I'm just gonna play it for, like, an hour.
And then, like, five hours passed.
So, like, I highly suggest you to not play Schedule 1, because I was not doing work for the last two days.
Oh, damn.
I got, like, I got, like, I got, like, scolded by my manager, because he was like, you gotta write that tweet draft for your sponsor.
And then I was like, and then I lied.
And I was like...
You lied!
It's okay.
I lied, and I was like, sorry, I just got home.
Sponsor, don't listen.
Sponsor.
But the thing is, but the thing is, I didn't need to finish writing that tweet, uh, the draft for yesterday, because it was actually for next week.
So I was like, oh, okay, I got it done early.
That's how you, that's how you justify it.
Got it.
Because I, I was like, oh, sorry, I just got home, like, an hour ago.
But in, in actuality, in reality, I got home, like, four hours ago.
Does your manager watch your stream?
He's asleep now.
Because that's why I checked if he was online before I said that.
I was like, okay, is he online?
Okay, he's offline.
He doesn't know.
Guys, don't timestamp this part.
Oh, yeah, that chat totally listens every time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The one time I said, don't timestamp, they'll definitely, you know.
They'll listen, they'll listen.
Listen, or I'll send, or I'll continue the cycle.
She will retweet the video, you guys.
I will continue the cycle if you timestamp it.
Okay, play the game.
I booted the game.
Don't worry.
Yeah, but you booted it.
I booted it.
All right.
Screen share.
Oh, yeah.
Can you just watch with the stream itself?
All right.
How is it still early access?
It says, visage early access.
No way.
There's no way.
This game has to be done by now.
Is it not?
It should be.
Oh, my God.
Why am I streaming at 1440p?
You are not getting that quality.
It doesn't say early access for me.
It's like early access for, like, your screen.
Like, when you game capture it.
Yeah, I'm giving you 1080.
You're not getting 1440p.
I need to get this thing off the screen.
He's just dot, dot, dot, dot.
I can just delete it.
Actually, no.
I'm keeping it in our chat logs.
Actually, you know what?
Good.
I'm going to screenshot that you said this.
As, like, evidence?
Wait, I'll be like...
I'm editing my message.
Send this to five people.
Or you'll get bored.
Continue the cycle.
There.
Now you can screenshot it.
I already feel like screenshotting it is, like, a curse.
It's gonna break my computer.
You're like, I give you permission to tweet the screenshot of the screen.
Send this to five people.
You'll get bored.
Yeah.
I don't know what.
I don't want to do that.
I don't even want to do that.
Oh, then you'll get bored, man.
He's gonna get you.
Look at him.
He's so hungry.
I don't think he's hungry.
He actually looks quite full.
He'll never be satisfied.
How hungry.
Oh, man.
Back at it again.
I would count down the days when I have to do a part two.
All right.
I think the worst part is that I have no idea where any of the pills are.
I've not been grabbing any, like, survival equipment.
Does it reset after each chapter?
No.
No, because there is a chance.
Why do we have a lizard map?
Yeah, you have a chance to actually softlock yourself.
No, that's evil.
It is.
That's why I'm, like, really afraid.
No, that's evil.
I'm really scared of softlocking myself right now.
All right.
Okay.
So, we just...
Wait, where...
Oh, yeah.
This is...
It's the...
Where you put the...
What was it?
Yeah, back up.
A finger or something?
I don't remember.
Oh, so...
Yeah, so we're back here.
I mean...
Do I have a light, right?
Yeah.
I'll just put the light here.
No, that's a candle.
I don't know where the...
That's a candle.
Where the lights are supposed to go.
In the lamps.
Wait, it's dark.
Where's the...
Right there.
What?
Oh, there you go.
Wait, how am I going crazy?
Oh, my God.
How am I going crazy already?
This is not good.
What do you mean you're going crazy?
It gave me, like, the little...
That thing where it was, like...
Oh, there's, like...
Don't stand in the deck.
Don't stand in the...
Yeah, yeah.
I was, like...
How...
How is it?
Am I already crazy?
Wait.
You missed one behind you?
Yeah, but I need to fix this.
Oh.
Okay.
There you go.
Did I use my flashlight?
No, I...
What?
Okay.
All right.
Time to start the next chapter.
It's this one.
What's this?
I don't know the key, but, like...
I don't know.
I don't know what's what.
If...
If he can't...
If he has this, that means that whoever's chasing me can't walk properly.
So he can't get to me as fast.
Ah.
Wait.
Someone said...
You know there's a storage room downstairs full of items.
Oh.
Is that true?
Okay.
We'll grab that later.
Yeah, but I have to go to the basement.
And I don't want to go to the basement right now.
All right.
You could.
No.
I'm worried something's gonna show up.
If I go to the basement.
I have...
I'm a little concerned about that.
All right.
I brought the game volume up.
What?
Oh, no.
I was just reading it.
Okay.
Yeah?
Wait.
I actually need a blow...
Oh.
Whoa.
What was that?
I heard a slam.
The floor shot.
Yeah.
Okay.
Before I start...
Oh.
Okay.
Before I start the game...
Let me, like, grab water.
You go entertain chat real quick.
What?
Okay.
Are you gone?
Hello?
Okay.
Hey, guys.
I think...
I might leave in the middle of the stream to go get pizza.
What have I left right now to go get pizza?
She'll never...
She'll never play the game, though.
Send the link.
No!
I don't want to look at it anymore.
Because I didn't get that pizza last week.
I've, like, since been craving my pizza.
Well, I tried to have the pizza last week.
Is pizza all you eat?
No!
But I...
But I burned my...
So I kind of want pizza.
Oh.
Never mind.
She's gone.
Set up a voice box that just randomly says words.
It'll be like, behind you.
Behind you.
Behind me?
Yeah.
Oh.
What's behind me, huh?
What are you trying to do?
What are you trying to set up in my chat, huh?
No, I was saying...
I was saying the pizza.
I want pizza.
Yeah, but what does...
What's that in context of behind me?
Huh?
I don't know.
What happens if you look behind you?
The pizza might be behind me.
A wall?
Why'd you put your shades on?
It's like, okay.
Because I forgot I binded that.
Do you have a stream deck?
I do, but I...
I'm lazy.
Because if you...
If you get the stream deck...
And then you turn off, like, the key binds...
It still works.
Yeah, I know.
But I'm lazy.
Just that lazy.
I'm not lazy.
I'm just a lazy cat.
You know, like, the type of cat that just...
I've never owned a cat, so this is all assumptions on how cats are, like, from watching videos.
You mean Garfield?
Yeah.
From watching Garfield.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I found out recently that you're not supposed to give your cat milk.
Like, it's all, like, a myth.
Like, what happens?
Do they explode?
Like...
No, I think cats are just somewhat lactose intolerant.
Wait, they're lactose intolerant?
Yeah.
Then why do they drink their mom's milk?
I don't...
If they're lactose intolerant, then why do they...
Wait, if your lactose...
Well, babies drink...
If you're lactose intolerant...
Because it's, like, a different species.
I don't know.
It's different milk.
So, like, if you're lactose intolerant...
I mean, if you're a baby...
As long as, like...
As long as it's a human milk, it's okay.
So you can fish your...
If you're a baby, you're probably exploding shits anyway.
So it's kind of...
How would you tell?
Oh!
That's true.
So, like, you can just give your baby lactose...
Like, you can just give your baby milk and it doesn't matter.
Because they're always shitting anyway.
Yeah.
I think that's probably how it is.
You're saying you can develop lactose intolerant as a mutation?
So, like, if you get lactose intolerant...
Like, if you become lactose intolerant...
Can you still...
And you're older?
And you really want milk?
Can you just drink human milk?
Or is that frowned upon in society?
Oh, no.
We're...
We're encroaching on a different...
A different...
I think...
You're like...
Stop...
Stop the conversation!
We can't...
We've already hit our fetish quota.
That's not a fetish!
Yes, it is!
One question!
And you really miss milk.
And it's like...
You know, it's your favorite type of drink.
Or, like, food or whatever.
And so, like...
And you have lactate!
You...
Or you drink...
You drink...
What do you mean?
You have lact...
You drink your own milk?
What?
What do you mean?
What do you think lactate is?
You said lactate!
I was like, what did the...
What do you mean?
No, lactate!
Aid!
I'm not just telling you...
Lactate!
So you can drink your own milk.
Yeah, I was like, okay.
I was like, damn it, that's freaky.
I was like, you're on your own with that one.
I'm not touching that.
Just induce lactation because it's from your own body.
Yeah, from your own body.
You gotta feed your milk obsession.
I think if someone were to do that, they'd have much other issues.
Yeah, I was just gonna say, like, what is, okay, there's that.
But I was like, isn't like, it's like, it's like drinking urine.
Where, like, if you drink urine, it's like, it's bad for you.
I'm taking the bottle away from you.
What did I tell you?
Unpause the game right now.
I probably had two sips.
We'll take another sip.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I meant, it's like drinking sweat.
Like, drinking...
I meant that, guys.
Alright, alright, alright, let's start the game, guys.
Yeah, let's start the game!
Woo!
You know what you signed up for.
Unfortunately, yeah.
Alright.
You played Craft Mine, or the all-seeing eyes.
Oh yeah, I played Craft Mine.
I was Craft Mine.
It was actually really good.
Oh, I just realized I had the fucking lighter on the entire time, that's not good.
Oh yeah, it's gonna waste it.
The all-seeing eyes.
What do we do here?
I don't know.
I don't know where I'm supposed to go.
Like...
Uh...
Is it parents' bedroom?
Game is...
Guys, there's no volume in here, in general.
Oh, there's a wheelchair now.
Yes, there is.
I hear tons of volume.
I know, but...
Oh, really?
Oh.
Yeah.
There's a wheel...
Was this wheelchair there before?
Oh, it was definitely not there.
I don't remember this.
It was definitely...
Oh!
I'm paraplegic now.
Hello.
We can play that...
That new Switch game that's coming out.
Wait, what new Switch game that's coming out?
The, like, wheelchair basketball.
There's wheelchair basketball?
Yeah, it's for the Switch too.
Oh!
I heard, like, it's gonna be more expensive than, like, what it was advertised.
Oh my god!
What is happening?
What the fuck is...
Am I gonna get abducted?
What the hell?
Why are we screaming?
Oh no!
Don't make me walk!
No!
I love my wheelchair!
He grew back his legs.
Yeah.
He just...
It was really painful...
It's like, it's like...
It was like a lizard.
Yeah and then they're like...
They're, like, baby legs too.
They're...
They have to grow...
It's like grow a baby.
Put it in water for it to grow on.
Have you ever had those grow-a-babies?
Grow-a-ba-b... Oh, I've had like, lizard ones.
Yeah, I had like a grow-a-baby one.
Where it was like, a little like, you know, pruned-up baby.
And then you like put it in a water cup and then it just becomes a bigger pruned-up baby.
Make the game louder.
Alright, don't worry.
You're being told to do so.
I'm pausing the game so I can make the game louder.
That's the only reason she's pausing the game, guys.
Yes, that's the one time.
Oh, there he is.
Hello.
Oh, oh my god.
Hello there.
Are you okay?
An actual person.
He's a real man.
I can't.
I got invisible walls.
Oh.
Sir.
Look, that's the fourth person I'm going to send the chainmail to.
That's the second person I'll send the chainmail to.
You have to send it to five people or...
That's why he looks so distressed.
Yeah, no, he's scared.
He's like, he heard it and he disappeared.
He disappeared.
No, he received it and he doesn't know what to do with it.
He's just like... He's reading it.
This is what it was.
This is what he was reading.
He's like, who do I send this to?
It's so horrible.
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
You get so off.
This is so sad.
It's like a table facing the wall.
Like, where's the... Yeah, and the binds are closed.
Where are you... Like, you can literally move the table, like, three steps to the left.
Yeah.
What?
Well, something's wrong with the radius.
What the fuck is this?
Oh.
What is it?
It better not be what I think it is.
It's the boar link.
Who said this to me?
Who could it be?
That's gonna be the whole storyline.
Oh, he's mad.
I'm sorry for sending it to you.
Oh, no.
He hates books.
He's trying to find his phone books.
He can send it to five more people.
Put on a shirt, my guys.
Yeah.
You know, Pisa, you think you get me...
Is it like a miniature camera?
Oh, he's paranoid.
He's schizo.
Oh, he thinks people are watching him.
Oh, that's probably what he thought was in the radio.
Oh, remember they're always watching, like, the eye thing or whatever?
So, he thinks everybody's watching him.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do I just go up?
Up I go.
Up you go.
It's so dark.
I don't think I go up.
It's an invisible wall.
Oh, just kidding.
Wait, where do I go?
Do I go to this chair?
Do I just sit in it?
No.
Oh, here.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, I forgot he went the other way.
Oh, we go to the...
I guess we go here.
No, it's too dark for that.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he sees me?
Whoa.
I thought it was just a ghost.
I was like, g-g-g-ghost.
G-g-g-ghost.
Shoot me.
Oh, oh, he did.
What are you going to do?
Shoot me?
Ask and you shall receive.
I...
Oh, he sees Shadow Man.
Oh, my God, Tar Man.
Oh, Tar Man.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I don't like that.
Leave me alone.
I don't like that.
You're going to see that guy too, maybe.
Yeah, I was going to say, I feel like I'm going to see him now.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is that pillows?
No.
I don't know where to go.
Wait, there's the tar.
Nah, that...
It's from the previous chapter, I think.
Oh!
I think you found where to go.
The door is...
Oh, the...
Oh!
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
I'm going to...
The eye seems to be alive.
Just stab it.
Alright, yeah, I'll just poke it.
Got your eye.
He-heh.
Is there, like, light here?
Yeah.
I don't trust anything.
Oh, there's another wheelchair.
Yeah.
Oh, you just sit in the wheelchair every time?
I'm just immersing myself in my role, you know?
Yeah.
What's that word called when you're, like, fully immersed?
Like, actors who get fully into their role?
Yeah, I'm just method acting.
I want to be that guy.
I don't think you do.
I want to be just like him when I grow up.
Oh my god, you're going to see the tar, man.
Oh, never mind.
He made a new room.
God wants me.
Because I've been a good...
I've been a good girl.
I've been a good kitty.
This is extreme home renovation.
Move that bus!
Oh my god, the loading times.
Dr. Smith?
Oh!
Where am I?
Yes, sorry.
I'm with you.
I have the information you requested concerning the patient that came in tonight.
Okay.
He claims that someone broke into his house and tried to strengthen him.
He used his firearm in an attempt to defend himself.
What's weird is that there's nothing in the police report that indicates...
Oh, so...
He thinks there's someone there?
But they all seem self-inflicted.
Oh.
See, that's the problem.
I had neighbors.
Why is that a problem?
The neighbors have to ruin the fun.
Yeah, we're having a party over here.
Yeah.
Party crashers.
Who called the cops?
Had really bad cases of what?
Scope-pop-phobia?
The fuck is scope-pop-phobia?
Maybe that's the people spying on you?
Spying on you?
Yeah.
Oh, game volume low.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll do it up a little more.
You guys don't need to hear this.
They're not- it's not important information.
Scooby-phobia?
Scooby-phobia.
Scooby-dooby.
Oh, Metal Gear.
Oh my god.
It's been nine years.
Don't open dead inside.
Don't dead open inside.
All right, let me open.
And then it becomes a zombie game.
Wait, this is literally the same layout as the beginning of Metal Gear.
It's The Walking Dead.
I'm Rick.
I'm Rick now.
What is that dog?
Wait, what is that?
Why is it above my head?
Is it a dog or a goat?
I can't tell.
It's a dog.
It's like the poodles.
It's like, don't worry.
Oh.
The dog will save you.
It's like a renaissance version of a dog.
Kind of messed up looking.
Why is it like above my bed?
Like, is she gonna hear me or something?
Okay, so I have no items on me.
So, I can't go crazy if I have no items on me.
There's a diamond dog.
Yeah, exactly.
I like how you agreed with that.
You don't know.
I don't know the reference.
Yeah.
I'm just be like, what?
Code white in room 2-3-2-3.
I'll go to the exit.
Wait, there's someone watching me.
See that?
You can go to 3-2-3.
Hell yeah, I see that.
I'll just leave.
Go to 3-2-3, maybe?
Or I could just leave.
Wait, I can open this.
Oh, I don't like that.
Ew, hospital areas are gross.
I don't like this.
Wait, but it says exit.
It says an exit.
Do I have to go to 3-2-3?
Like you told me to?
You could keep going to the exit.
That's 3-0-1.
Is that the exit?
All right.
What is this?
Oh, wait, what's that down there?
It doesn't seem...
It's just a can.
Somebody's just littered outside.
Someone littered in the hospital.
I can't believe it.
When anyone's thinking of the children.
I think this is where I came out.
Yeah.
Oh, you could just...
Oh.
This is where I came out.
I don't think so.
Yeah, it is.
This is my bed.
It is?
Oh wait, no, it is not.
No, it's not.
Yeah.
They all look the same.
It's like a hospital or something.
Yeah, it's like all the rooms are like...
The same.
Oh, did you see like a picture on Twitter?
There's some hospital have like a children's like decorated bedrooms and stuff.
And there was this lady that went to the emergency room and they put her in like a fucking ocean themed room with like a giant octopus.
What?
That sounds awesome.
Yeah, but like if you're...
If you're on like some form of like, um...
Oh.
What's it called?
The sleep meds.
You wake up to see a giant octopus in your room.
A giant fucking octopus in your room after a surgery?
Okay.
Yeah, I think I would.
Okay, I think this is where I came from.
Where the fuck is 323?
Yeah, coming out of anesthesia and then you're just like...
Yeah.
303.
I think you can explore a lot of these rooms.
Wait, what the heck was that?
You didn't even look in there.
My game crashed.
Fatal error!
You explored too many rooms.
No way!
You did not progress the game fast enough.
Whoops.
Wait, oh no.
Alright, I'll screen share.
I wonder how much it will...
I think I would just be in the room, right?
Most likely.
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Alright, I hear you.
They're like, explore faster.
Wait, did you share it?
Yeah.
It's not up.
Oh.
This is shared.
It's up, it's up.
Okay, let me make sure it's at 1080p.
Okay, yeah, you're not getting 1440p.
I'm not...
She's denying me!
If you want 1440p, go open the stream.
You know what?
Fine, I see it in lower quality.
It's less scary.
You get to see it in a full HD.
Or...
I could go to options.
Go to video.
Turn everything down.
Yeah, there you go.
Okay, I gotta pee, so you go find 323.
Okay, 323.
I can find 323.
I should be here, because it's like...
Forward.
I didn't go forward yet.
I swear to God, if things start happening when, like, she went to the bathroom, I swear to God.
Oh, there's a key!
Oh, I got the key!
I mean, I don't have any items, so like, it can't be that scary.
I also need to blow my nose.
Give me a sec.
Nose break!
Alright.
Alright, it can't be bad.
I'm not going crazy, and I have no items on me.
So, like, nothing's gonna be chasing me or anything.
I can, like, take this slow.
It is a little concerning that there's nobody else in the hospital but me.
It's almost like, like, Walking Dead right now.
What could be happening?
Stop stalling.
Don't worry.
I don't want...
I want to make sure she doesn't miss out on the good stuff that's happening.
I'm just making sure.
I'll wait out here like a good cat.
Don't dead.
Don't dead inside open.
It's alright.
It's literally right here.
I'll sit in the waiting room.
I'll sit in the waiting room like a good kitty.
Check out more paintings.
There's more paintings?
It's just renaissance paintings right here.
Not that interesting.
There's just...
that.
And then there's some books here.
That's like...
A Sunny Day.
What a nice book.
And then there's this painting by Van Gogh.
And then...
And then there's like the lovely nurse's office.
Where they're doing math homework.
Why the fuck is there math homework at the...
Why is there math homework in the nurse's office?
Like who the fuck is doing math here?
Who the fuck brought their kid to...
To a scary hospital?
Oh no, I'm stuck.
Oh no.
Okay, wait.
No, no.
I can fix this.
Oh no, I have too many things in my hand.
How did I pick up this chair?
How did...
Get this chair.
Get this chair out of my hand!
Oh god.
Okay, I got one thing out of my hand.
All right.
Figured it out.
I don't know how...
I don't know how I had a chair in my hand.
But everything's okay.
Yeah.
Look, see?
I waited for you before I went inside the room.
Thanks.
I'm gonna order pizza.
Ooh.
So I don't burn it myself this time.
Oh yeah.
Is this not 323?
Or is it 4?
Wait, what do you mean?
You...
You waited?
Oh.
Oh yeah, I said I waited for you.
Oh yeah, there you go.
Yeah, I wanna make sure you didn't miss out.
Oh, it's right here.
Oh yeah.
Nothing's going on in there.
Yeah, nothing's going on in there.
It's like happening behind you.
Wait, there's nothing in here.
Okay.
Yeah, there's nothing in here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Did I open the wrong door?
No, this is the right door.
No?
That's the right one?
Yeah, what the fuck?
What am I supposed to do in here?
Oh.
I have to put my hand through it.
What is that?
I'm sorry.
The quality is so low, I can't really tell what's going on.
It's 1080.
Sorry, I don't get my HD experience.
Sorry.
It's just like really...
Yeah, it's just like so pixelated.
I can't see anything.
Yeah, yeah.
That like the 10 pixels I needed.
Like I can only see at 1440p.
If anything's lower, I'm legally blind.
Yeah, sorry.
Where's my 4K?
I need to like break it?
But how?
A sledgehammer?
Yeah, but I didn't see it.
I didn't see any hammers or anything near me.
My friend.
About my special eyes.
Look, look with your special eyes.
What do you see?
Oh?
Oh.
Are you getting chased?
Wait, is there somebody?
I don't think so.
Just turn around.
Is there someone there?
No.
I think it's coming from the chair.
Spooky chair.
Oh, nobody's around me.
Check in the room.
Go...
Yeah, check in here.
There's nothing in here, no?
That's where I found the key.
I keep accidentally picking up stuff here.
Uh oh.
I don't like this.
If I slowly walk, nothing bad will happen to me, right?
Yeah.
That's how horror games work.
Just slowly walk over.
Oh, wow.
Wait, who's crying?
Why are you crying?
Who's crying over here?
I don't hear crying.
I think that's you.
Oh, it's over here.
Look.
No, it says cries.
Cry.
Oh.
Yeah, I was like, where's the crying?
Oh, there it is.
There's my crowbar.
Hey!
Oh my god, we're in Half-Life!
Yeah!
We're in Half-Life!
Now it's a real Half-Life game.
All right.
I feel safer with Crowbar.
Yeah, me too.
I feel a lot safer.
Half-Life, let's go!
You cannot escape Half-Life.
Break open the...
Break open the vending machines.
Wait, I'm lost.
Oh, it's right here.
Everything looks the same.
Why can't hospital look different?
I got lost in the hospital recently.
Wait, why were you at the hospital?
For my grandma.
And I got lost, like, for a long time.
Couldn't figure out where to go.
Oh yeah, quick save.
I forgot.
Oh, it'll tell you that you can't use it.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Quick save.
Wait, what was quick save again?
I don't remember.
Saving is disabled.
Why is it always disabled whenever I want to save?
That's right.
Life's not fair.
Nope.
All right, here we go.
I just...
Oh wait, no.
There's another door here.
Oh, there's another key.
No, there's a key.
It says meeting room, third floor.
All right.
And I can save now, right?
I can save now.
You can save now, right?
Okay, all right.
Nope, all right.
That's fine.
What is the point?
What is the actual point?
That's fine.
I don't need a save.
There's no way that this is...
That it just...
It just decided to be like...
No saving for you.
What?
Oh my god, he can walk!
Oh, fuck off!
I think you need to go!
I thought you were there for the EJ!
He can walk!
Why can't you walk?
Wait, he's not even that close to me.
I think he's pretty slow.
Oh my god, the flashing lights.
I don't like that.
Wait, where is he?
I'm gonna...
He's real slow.
Yeah, he's so slow.
Let's go towards the red now.
Yeah, I feel like I have to go here.
Like, it's not even...
He's just a man.
Like, it's not even that scary.
It's just a dude.
Oh my god!
A man!
Oh, he was right there the whole time!
Wait, but he is half naked.
This guy never puts on a t-shirt.
I think that's the scariest part.
Because you know he has no fear if he's not wearing anything.
He fears nothing.
He fears...
Anyone who doesn't fear society's judgment is terrifying.
Oh my god.
My fridge, like, went off, too.
Like, I heard, like, my fridge outside did, like, the...
sound.
Like, the ice maker?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The transit wing?
Where the fuck is that?
Great question.
I can't go out.
It's jammed.
What's on the TV?
All right.
I can't wait.
Oh, exit.
Oh!
Where is the exit?
Oh, it's the window.
I have to find a window?
A window that says exit all over it.
Yeah.
Oh, can I pick...
Oh, I can pick up a flashlight.
Wait, there's footprints on the ground.
There is?
Oh.
Wait, he was on the table.
I think he also had pizza.
Oh, I can push this.
Ah!
Oh, now things can be pushed.
I swear, though, this is probably going to be a door that opens the other way.
Oh, never mind.
Nope.
It's fine.
I lied.
Follow the footprints.
It ended.
Did he, like, throw wings or something?
Like, what happened?
Like, did a miracle happen?
He cleaned...
He cleaned his feet.
He got Red Bull.
Oh, nice.
How nice of them.
I don't think they would offer that at a hospital.
I don't think that's, like...
If you mix medication with Red Bull...
That does not seem like a good time.
Well, it's a good thing you're at the hospital.
Oh, that's true!
You didn't try anything at a hospital.
Oh, hey.
He's right there.
I'm gonna walk over to him.
Yeah, go follow him.
Yeah, what are you doing over there, sir?
Oh, he's gone.
Wait, is that the window?
Oh, no.
No...
Probably not.
It says I have a key to the...
I don't remember what it said.
Wait, meeting room, third floor, the one...
Oh, no, no, that's the transit wing.
Oh, the transit wing.
Where the fuck is the transit wing?
Uh...
Is that the staircase?
Try it.
Go to the stair.
Wait, check the...
Check the signs here.
To the right.
Something chasing me?
No?
I think that was a wheelchair.
Oh, no.
A wheelchair.
It says it's locked.
Is it that wing?
Who's angry at me?
Oh, wait.
Maybe this is it.
Oh, no.
No, that's a psychiatric.
Psychiatric ward.
Where's the transit wing?
Oh, is that the exit?
No.
Wait, it's over here.
It's all ready.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, exit.
Alright.
Okay, easy.
Look at that.
We're so good at puzzles.
I know.
Wow.
Oh, hey, he's over here.
Oh, he's right there.
John, do a flip.
Don't do it!
I'll follow him.
Yeah.
Alright, don't worry, sir.
I'll save you!
Yeah!
What's the worst that could happen?
He's gonna jump at you right now... We literally said it was gonna happen!
I thought he would do it in front of me!
He
literally called this happening.
Okay, I thought it would be in front of me.
Oh, wait.
My sanity is decreasing fast.
What the hell?
We just got here!
I just got back.
You can't do this to me.
Is this the house?
Yeah, it is.
But there's trees now.
There's trees growing everywhere.
Do I have to go this way?
I like what they did with the place.
Yeah, just follow the big veiny one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, there's the eyes.
Hello.
Oh.
Just... Okay.
Okay.
Like, why did it do that?
Why did it just... Oh, that guy might need an eye.
And that might need an eye.
I think I need to poke their eyes out, right?
Yeah, see?
That one.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Take that eye.
And then I need to poke another eye out.
Yeah, get rid of their eyes.
Oh.
No eyes here.
I feel like there's... They're like connected.
I feel like the ones that are connected to the vein need eyes, right?
No.
No, no.
They're like...
Cause, like, last time I poked eyes out.
I need to find the remaining eyes.
Okay.
Wherever they are.
The eyes.
Special eyes.
Wait, was that one?
No.
There's no eyes in there.
Where are all the eyes?
What's the music for?
I don't know.
Are you getting chased?
I think I'm getting chased, but I'm too ignorant to know.
We ignore?
I'm too stupid to realize I'm getting chased right now.
Oh, there it is.
There's the other one.
We do not perceive?
There.
That should be... It was two.
There, there.
How do you know it was two?
Cause I looked!
I looked at it!
Okay, man, you are not paying attention.
Sorry, I'm waiting for my pizza.
The only issue is I forgot where the actual area door is.
Oh, you'll find it.
There it is.
Oh, it's over here.
Was I being chased at all?
Like, was that it?
No, I think they just wanted to, like, spook you a little.
Alright, here's another chair.
Yeah!
I need pizza to think.
Hello.
I'm just messy acting.
I'm just like him.
Oh!
Man!
Wait.
Gosh, I wish this guy would put on a shirt.
Oh my god!
Wait!
Oh!
This is not you!
You don't have hair!
Oh!
I think he has a lot less than me.
He's messy!
Okay, but, like, where's his hair, though?
Oh!
Oh, there it is!
Oh, there he is!
Nice.
I wish he would put on his eyes, you...
I know!
Put on your eyes, you freak!
His eyes, his nose, his mouth.
Conformed us aside, he sounded a beauty!
And he's making all the other guys take off their shirts, too!
He's like...
He's like the messiah.
Anti-strike witches.
Anti...
What the fuck is this?
Strike...
What?
You know strike witches?
How they're anti-pants?
He's anti-shirt.
There's an actual...
Is that a cult?
Where, like, they just don't wear pants?
No, it's...
Well, it's an anime.
Oh!
That is like...
Oh, look!
Yeah, it's a cult.
It's a cult.
It's just a...
Oh, saving...
Oh!
Oh, he just walks away.
He was like...
He was...
He was voguing.
He was, like, striking a pose.
Strike a pose.
And then just decided, like...
Yeah, I'm done.
Yeah, like, my job here...
It was like a flash mob.
He got moved to the next area.
Where's our guy?
Where's the next part of...
Oh!
Oh, guys!
Hey, guys!
I don't think they, like, that I touched him.
I don't think they...
Yeah, I don't think they wanted me in there.
Yeah, I don't think...
No, I...
I don't think they wanted me there.
They're like, why are you wearing a shirt?
This is taking a long time.
Yeah!
No shirt!
No tie!
All service!
No life!
Sir, you're a bit too close.
Your skin touched my skin.
And I don't like that.
We need to have at least, like, five centimeters apart.
He felt fabric and he, like...
Yeah!
He felt the...
Oh, wow.
That's where it saved.
That's kind of crazy.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
They're a little underwear.
Stop!
Don't look at their crotches!
It's right in my face!
Whoa!
Wow!
There's women in this gold!
Yeah, are you okay now?
Are you okay now?
Can I do that now?
Are you...
All is well.
Oh, so that works.
Okay.
I like how the...
The key for the stairs is just like a little zigzag drawing.
Yeah, it's like stairs.
People will get what it means.
I don't really know.
I'm like, you get it, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I'm experiencing something.
Oh, my ears.
Ow.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, I'm supposed to run.
Oh, I think I'm supposed to run now.
Check, just in case.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're kinda...
They're kinda close.
They're kinda very close now.
There you go.
Alright.
Are they gonna be outside?
That was like the shortest...
Oh, that was the shortest chase scene I've ever had.
Ever had.
Yeah.
They're like...
Saving is disabled.
I don't think saving is ever enabled in this game.
Wait, but it's red.
I just keep going down?
I guess I just keep going down.
But what if...
But this is an emergency.
It's not a fire emergency.
Alright.
Wait, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Again?
Yeah.
Last time I didn't...
I got water.
This time it's a bathroom emergency.
Oh, okay, okay.
Guys, this looks exactly like Metal Gear.
It's the MGSV map.
It really, really feels like that.
It feels exactly like the Metal Gear map.
Just the...
The ho...
The hall...
I almost said hotel.
The hospital hallways are just a little bit different, I think.
But it's like almost exactly it.
Call me Ishmael.
It's literally the same hospital.
I can't do this.
All I see is Metal Gear.
Even the stairway.
Oh god.
The crowd of dudes in the hallway.
Oh my gosh!
Yes!
You're right!
There's hospitals besides Metal Gear.
No, no.
You don't understand though.
Like this specifically has too many parallels.
This one...
This specifically has way too many parallels.
Like the way you wake up.
It actually...
It looks exactly like the room.
I don't know.
I'm not saying that it's the same map.
But...
I'm not saying it's the same map.
The thighs look a lot like it.
If only we got a gun.
I'm afraid it's been...
Nine years.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep!
Oh yeah.
I need my eye patch.
There we go.
Wait, did that work?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm tired.
Sorry.
It all comes back to Metal Gear.
I want my pizza.
I'll become...
I'll be...
I'll have more...
More brain power once I eat.
I...
I got something today.
And...
Oh my gosh.
You know what's so frustrating?
Is when you order something.
And you tell them no of something.
And they include it.
You know?
And then you're just like...
My meal...
It's not ruined.
I still ate it.
But I ate it...
With...
With disdain.
I was just like...
Like I was so...
Why'd you...
Why didn't you...
Take it out?
What?
Hmm...
So annoying.
Oh, welcome back.
What was so annoying?
I ordered something.
And I told them not to add something in it.
And they still did.
Wait, what was it?
It was bean sprouts.
Ew.
Wait, you...
What?
What kind of pizza has bean sprouts on it?
What kind of pizza did you order?
It's not pizza.
It was earlier.
It was...
Oh!
And like with bean sprouts...
It was bean sprouts.
And then like...
I don't like bean sprouts.
So I had to like pick them out.
But it's like...
Individual bean sprouts.
Yeah, so you have to like individually pick them up.
Yeah, I do that with...
Yeah.
Pickles.
And mushrooms.
Oh yeah, I do that with mushrooms.
Yeah, I don't...
I don't like mushrooms either.
It's like a type...
It's like...
I don't want to eat a fungus.
Like you saw what happened in Last of Us.
Like...
What if this one mushroom I eat is that mutated mushroom?
Yeah, I think about that with almonds.
Oh my god.
What about almonds?
Because almonds, before they were catered to humans, they have arsenic in it.
Wait, what?
That's why arsenic smells like almonds.
Why do you know what arsenic smells like?
I've watched detective shows.
That doesn't explain the smell.
Oh, cyanide, cyanide, cyanide, cyanide.
I haven't had my pizza.
I was like, how do you know what cyanide smells like?
Like, you just believe or detect like they're like, don't drink cyanide.
It smells just like almonds.
Don't drink cyanide.
No, they'll let go and they'll be like this person.
There's I smell.
I smell almonds right now.
Yeah, feel like it might be poison.
It might be so.
So if you eat a random food and it smells like almonds, You might be poisoned by cyanide.
Or, second hypothesis, there's almonds in it.
Or, yeah, and then you have a nut allergy.
If you have a nut allergy, you either die by cyanide or die by almonds.
Win-win, maybe.
Win-win, yeah.
So to avoid being poisoned, just have a nut allergy.
So you can avoid all types of nuts.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Then you don't have any other problems in your life.
Yeah, don't you have to get that.
You only don't have to worry about...
Yeah, you just have to worry.
Just need to make sure you have an EpiPen near you at all times.
Oh my god, the fountain is broken.
No!
Think of the water pill.
That's the real horror.
The real horror is the water pill.
Not the water pill!
No!
Where am I supposed to go?
It never told me where to go.
Let's explore.
Alright.
There's so many wheelchairs here.
There's nobody on it.
It's a hospital.
A miracle happened.
There's so many abandoned wheelchairs because everyone could just miraculously stand again.
Yeah, everybody just started walking.
A miracle occurred!
Just like our shirtless guy.
Yeah!
Oh my god, this is a miracle hospital.
They all...
Yeah.
They cured walking.
They're really doing wonders here.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
They're doing such a good job.
That's why it's abandoned.
They just fixed everybody.
Yeah, nobody's sick anymore.
Yeah, nobody's sick in this hospital.
Orthopedic.
I don't think I'm not supposed to be here.
Like, this area...
This level seems like...
Very...
Whistle raid.
Very straightforward.
Like, linear.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one's a more linear chapter.
Yeah.
Which is my favorite type of chapter.
Oh, wait.
How about go to the door that's...
Yeah, covered in...
Yeah, I thought about that too.
Oh, wait, no.
There's a hand here.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah.
They're like, literally...
Like, guiding me.
School feeding you.
God, that's my favorite type of game.
Follow up of patient...
On request from Smith Walter.
Found her his tape.
Oh, yeah.
Also, does it sound a lot better now?
I don't even know.
Yeah, can you hear it, guys?
Gender male, age 28.
After Rakin's first evaluation...
No, this is supposed to be a miracle hospital.
What do you mean saying?
You're supposed to fix everybody.
Maybe he's like the one patient they never could fix.
Yeah.
Uh...
Brainwash?
Let's go.
From getting to them.
They're gonna get him.
From...
Getting to him.
Adding to the severity of his case, he is sometimes afflicted with hallucinations.
He has described these hallucinations...
Eyeless humanoid that keeps on watch- Oh, it's them!
Those little naked guys that we saw.
The shirtless men.
Yeah.
If they're eyeless, how are they watching you, dumbass?
Dumbass.
Yeah.
I wonder you're in the psychiatric ward.
Not even your hallucinations make sense.
They're so crazy.
Your hallucinations don't even follow...
The law.
Violent behaviors towards staff?
Oh, okay.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
I'm not...
Okay, so like...
Why is there math homework in my hospital?
Like...
Who's bringing their kid here to do their high school homework?
Ew!
It's just, uh...
Bring your kid to work then.
Like, there's like...
I see a fucking equation there.
I see fractions.
This is not science.
I like that big...
That man's, like, giant face in the newspaper.
Oh, yeah.
That guy?
I like this painting.
Yeah.
The jester.
The jester, yeah.
Nah, it looks like you.
All right.
I guess we move out of this place now.
Oh, yeah.
We have to bring the volume up a little bit.
Okay.
I brought it up a little bit, guys.
Oh.
Oops.
I actually tabbed out my OBS.
All right.
There we go.
Where else do I go after fractions?
Where's my yellow paint?
Yellow paint.
Hello.
We're a gamer here.
Gamer here.
Streamer here.
We need yellow paint.
That's more accurate.
Streamer here.
We need help.
Paint the signs yellow.
Oh.
There's people there.
There are?
I don't know.
There's the flashing light.
Sorry, the quality is so low, I can't see it.
Yeah, those ten missing pixels are fucking with me right now.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, here.
Oh, there's another key.
A key to...
Basement.
Okay, I actually don't know where the basement staircase is.
I was not keeping track.
What's he gonna do, clip through the wall like last time?
He's not a ghost, he's a real person.
Oh, I think that was...
Oh, no, he's still there.
Oh, he waited.
Oh, hello.
He waited!
Was he gonna do, climb up this table?
I think you can loop him, maybe.
He can't reach me!
Wait, he can't reach you!
He can't come up through this table!
That's right, I have the high ground!
He's really trying.
He's trying to kill me, guys.
I don't know where to go.
I think he really wants to kill me.
Come on, mister!
You...
Just...
Just come on!
Just turn around!
Turn around!
What are you gonna do?
That's right!
Let me just...
Yep.
Can you like...
There you go, there you go.
Oh!
He's like sulking in the corner.
I have the high ground now!
I think you could just...
Run.
I think you could just run.
What are you gonna do right here?
Oh!
He's gonna go back to the corner.
He's gonna keep running!
I just slowly opened the door.
I didn't figure out how to open the door.
Oh!
What's he gonna do?
He's gonna go back to the corner.
He doesn't know what to do.
He's so...
I can't open the door!
I can't get up!
My high ground protects me!
I can't accidentally close the door!
He just waxed me.
Oh wait, no he's gonna...
I'm not gonna lie!
We deserve that!
Oh shit!
Yeah, we did!
We fucking deserve what we did to him!
He...
He mad!
Okay, maybe you run past him.
Yeah, maybe I should've...
He's pretty fast though!
He's like actually running past you!
Yeah, he was like...
Yeah, I was like...
What's he gonna do?
He's...
He's crippled!
Like...
Oh shit!
Oh, that scared me!
That scared me more than...
Okay, alright.
Alright, let me feed him real quick.
He's angry.
He's upset at what you said!
He's like, you can't say that!
When's my feeding time, guys?
Where's my pizza?
I'm
back to my desk!
So you don't have to pause too long.
Alright, okay.
I'm back.
Alright, so now we know I have to...
I'm gonna go get a drink though.
Okay, I'll run.
While you do that.
Okay, yeah, just run.
Oh my god.
He's like right next to me.
He was right next...
Okay, where's the basement though?
Guys, where's the...
That's the one thing I don't know.
Okay, I'm outside.
He was like right behind me.
That's cheating.
That's actually cheating.
I should be safe now, right?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm okay now.
That thing can get me now.
I'm unstoppable.
I beat...
I beat a man on the...
On those like crutches.
I'm just that good.
Now where do I go?
To the other door.
Hehehehe.
He's on crutches.
Yeah, and I beat him in a race.
That's how good I am.
Oh, fuck it!
He's right behind me!
Okay, but he's not that fast though.
Like, look at him.
He's on crutches.
I can literally leisurely walk.
Look at him.
He's so slow.
Did you lose him?
No, he's like right here.
Oh.
He seems so fast in the office room.
Oh my god, is this the...
Okay, it is.
Okay, I saw stairs.
Ah, you got it!
Okay.
Yeah.
He's right there.
He's gonna pop out at you.
Nah.
He's gonna be like...
Ooh!
Wait, the light's gone.
Maybe...
Oh, maybe you're going back to the house.
Oh, maybe.
I'm having a vision right now.
I can't move.
Oh.
What happened?
What?
Load times.
What the fuck happened?
The game is loading.
They have to load me into the next...
Oh, there is the flashlight.
Oh, there is.
Yeah.
I was like, what do you mean?
They're just like, we gotta load you to the next level.
Just black out for a second.
Yeah, yeah, black out.
Just having a vision.
Look at all these...
No, it's saved.
Nice.
I don't have to save.
Nope.
Assume it's...
First door that opens.
Ooh.
I need to fix it.
It's a locker room.
Weaking.
I need to fix this hospital.
Oh, nice.
Control room.
Okay.
I just like how I don't have to manage pills right now.
I know.
Yeah.
That's the best part.
That's like the best part about this game.
What do I do?
Wait.
He won't let me pass.
There's something here.
Just jump.
Just that easy.
Just...
Just use your legs.
Okay.
That's insensitive.
There's people here that can't walk.
I can't just use my legs like that.
What if we're actually in the wheelchair then?
What if we're like...
We're slowly rolling around.
We're just like, please, won't somebody help us?
Is this the controller?
Oh, wait.
Oh, this is a room that was blocked by the locker.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
No, that's not...
No, JK.
I was just making stuff up and you were still agreeing.
Yeah.
I did agree.
You're a sheep.
You don't think for yourself.
I really didn't.
I didn't think for myself at all.
I just said, yeah, you're okay.
You're right.
Yeah, you're so right.
What is this layout?
I don't know.
I don't even...
I think this is the control room.
Yeah?
It sounds like it.
No, that's just the laundry.
It's the laundry room.
What laundry are they doing in here?
Wait, this is the only one that's on.
They won't open.
Until the cycle's done?
This is too...
This is too realistic.
I can open a washing machine whenever I want.
Yeah.
And you don't control me.
You're just...
Like, you know how when it's like five minutes or...
Until it's done and you're just...
You just can't wait that five minutes?
It's pretty much done.
Yeah, it's pretty much...
That's...
What's that five minutes gonna do?
If it's dry...
Well, I guess...
Oh.
It's not that.
What is the control room?
What controls it?
We actually just have to wait until...
It says we have to manually shut...
I think we have to manually shut...
Oh, is it this one?
No.
No, it's jammed.
I saw like a pirate thing on there, so I assumed it was...
A pirate?
Oh!
Is it here?
Oh, it's here!
Okay.
Ew, I don't like that.
Ew, what the hell?
I don't like it.
This is gross.
This is what peop...
This is what like...
People who go to trade school have to do.
The air conditioning man.
Haley Joel Osment got arrested.
You can't scare me anymore.
Wait, he got arrested?
What did he do?
It's apparently public intoxication.
Let me join him.
We'll see Doki Bird on the news tomorrow.
Okay, but like...
How would you know he was public...
Publicly intoxicated?
I think he would know.
It could just be like...
You know, celebrity things, you know?
Just like he's really eccentric.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's just a very eccentric celebrity.
You don't know that.
Yeah.
What the fuck is the power?
Oh.
It's not the one...
It's not the key though.
It wasn't?
But it was not.
I still have my key, see?
Oh, it's like...
Oh, it was from the other side.
I just unlocked it the other way.
It's like...
It's like the shortcut.
I'm playing Dark Souls.
I have a short...
I unlocked the shortcut.
Nice.
Which means I have to come back here.
Okay, is it here?
There's so many rooms you can't go in.
I know.
I'm like so confused.
Oh, it's here.
Ah, haha.
It wasn't even labeled.
How was I supposed to know?
You just explore.
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
Hello?
We're gonna start walking?
What is he gonna do?
Why is he just standing there?
Hey.
That's his thing.
Oh, he's gone.
That's what he's into.
He's just...
Into just standing in the corner.
Yeah, he wants to look really menacing and cool.
Okay, he doesn't know.
He's probably on his way over here, actually.
I think so, too.
I think that's why he's just gone.
Alright.
I'm in the power room.
Hello?
Crutch guy?
I don't think there should be water.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
In the power room?
Like...
Oh, I turned off the washing machine.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Time to wear some wet clothes.
My favorite.
Love that wet clothes.
Is he still in there?
No, he's not.
He's taking it!
Oh, my God!
What is he?
Guys, I don't think he's in there anymore.
That person tried to wear a shirt.
Rejected from the coat.
He was trying to get a shirt there.
No, I think you go back through the shortcut.
The washing machine was here.
Oh, was it?
Was it not here?
Or was it a shortcut?
Yeah, was it?
I don't remember.
You probably remember best!
No, I don't.
I'm so...
Oh, wait.
Okay, you're right.
That's what the shortcut's for.
Yep.
I am right.
No, I was talking to chat.
It was here, right?
Yeah, uh...
Yeah?
No, it was...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, because we were like, what the fuck?
Who made this layout?
Why is the layout like this?
Why is it like...
It's just like the house.
The person...
Yeah, yeah, like...
So the ghost won't get you.
The architect is the same architect.
Oh, it's the key!
What's his name?
I think that's his body.
Kyle Schaffner.
Janitor.
Full-time.
Hi, Kyle.
Born in 1978.
You think he's actually six feet?
I think he like fibbed it a little bit.
For his...
Yeah, just to be like, yeah, I'm a janitor.
I'm six foot eight.
Yeah.
Okay, I don't know.
I don't remember where this card unlocks, by the way.
There was a door that required a card key.
Oh, yeah.
And I don't remember.
I've already like forgotten 80% of this layout.
This layout is kind of whack.
Yeah.
Um...
It should be like around here, right?
Yes?
Hello?
Go back through the shortcut.
Door with card key?
Where are you?
Door with card key.
It's probably lit up.
It probably has like a little light on it.
Like...
Yeah.
Yellow paint.
I demand my yellow paint.
Where are you?
Oh, it's this one.
It's this door, right?
I'm pretty sure.
I don't...
Are you sure?
Yeah.
It's totally...
Nope.
That's where we were.
That's the controller room.
Huh?
So lost.
Uh...
At least we don't have to keep up our sanity.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is!
Yeah!
We're so smart!
We got it!
Oh!
Hey guys!
We're sh...
Oh!
Do you have to move them?
Wait, no.
He's moving by himself.
Oh.
Wait, no.
I'm moving.
Interact.
Yeah.
I think you're moving them out.
You're just...
Hello.
Oh.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh!
You see?
I don't think he likes that touch them.
And then you have to go and like move them and then...
He's like, why did you touch my collection?
I thought the elevator's probably too heavy with them in there.
It won't move.
Oh, that's true.
Okay.
I moved one guy.
That should be enough, right?
Wait.
Um.
It sounds kind of creaky.
You're like...
I can hear...
I don't know where he is!
Crouch man!
I'm trying to move him!
You can literally hear him coming!
I'm scared.
I think he's gone.
Wait, is he just gone?
Is he just gone?
Like, just like that?
Like, I moved...
Maybe.
I touched his things and he doesn't care anymore?
Alright, let's...
That might be him.
I think you gotta get all the bodies out.
What?!
They're not that heavy!
Alright.
Game logic.
They're not that heavy!
Were they like 10 tons each person?
You better hurry up!
He's coming!
No, he's not.
You're dying.
You better hurry up!
He's on his way!
I'm fucking paranoid right now.
Oh my god, I'm creating a scene.
He's almost there!
What is this?
I'm creating...
This is somebody's fantasy right now.
It's mine.
Oh my god, that guy's already excited.
Whoa, you see that?
I think I heard him.
He's whistling.
He's on his way.
He's like...
Here I come!
One, two, naked man's coming for you.
Alright, that guy.
Can I keep...
Can I just keep one of them with me?
No, they gotta go home.
They're not yours.
They're not yours to keep.
Oh, I hear him.
Oh, you gotta...
I think you should go.
I should keep this in hand.
Wait, what does that mean?
The fuck this...
What's the English is that?
What does that mean?
I should keep this in hands here?
What?
Did he get lost?
Don't worry, same.
Like, I got lost in the circular hallway.
Yeah, he's like...
He was like, was it this turn or that turn?
Where are we?
Where are we in my personal health?
Uh...
Whoa!
Oh!
Okay.
There's a lot more women here.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Ooh, all the ladies here there.
Ooh.
Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine if they were, like, weeping angels?
Oh, that's that.
No, I...
Oh, you played M-side yet, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that area with the weeping.
Oh my...
I hated that.
Hated that.
Wait, is he gonna kill me?
Fuck you, Dwayne.
I think he's just lining up.
Oh, no.
Why didn't you move?
I was!
I was moving backwards!
Why didn't you move out of the way?
I was curious!
I was curious if they...
If they just, you know, walked to the side or something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought he was gonna, like, you're like, out of the way!
Like, on your left, you know?
Uh, yeah, you thought he was just gonna, like...
I gave him the left side!
The hallway was big enough for two of us!
I...
Alright, here we go again.
Am I crouched yet?
No, okay.
My god, he has, like, bruises everywhere.
Like, where do I go?
I couldn't tell.
I thought it was, like, purple paint or something on there.
Like...
Can you save?
Oh, I have to go this way.
Fuck you, Dwayne.
Fuck you, Dwayne?
Who's Dwayne?
I'm Doki.
The rock!
Oh,
I heard something.
Something's crackling.
How about just close this door?
There we go.
We'll wait for you.
I just closed this door.
What's he gonna do?
Open it?
Alright.
Okay.
If you hide under there.
Is that who he's paranoid about?
Dwayne?
The rock Johnson?
He's just...
He's just everywhere, you know?
I'd be...
Everyone has their celebrity nemesis.
Do you have one?
Can't think of one on top of my head.
Who's your celebrity?
Is it...
Is it Haley Joel Osment or whatever?
Yeah, mine is Haley Joel Osment.
Wait, why?
What did he do to you?
I don't like how his face looks.
What?
Like a child?
That didn't grow up?
Yeah, like his face does not fit his head.
Like his face is so small and his head is so big.
You've been like...
You've been analyzing this man's face for a while.
That's why he's my celebrity nemesis.
I feel like...
Like he's just...
Wait, where do I go?
Oh, look, look, look!
There's another...
There's another TV.
Exit, exit, exit.
I can't open this.
Well, you went to the wrong way then.
You messed up.
Oh, there's so many doors.
No!
Wait, that's not fair.
She went through the door.
Wait, she can do that?
Uh-oh.
Uh, get on top of like a...
Desk like before.
Um...
You think she knows I'm here?
Yeah.
You think she...
Run!
Yay!
A perfectly executed loop?
I didn't even know there was a loop there.
Not gonna lie.
I didn't...
I didn't either.
Oh wait, follow the footsteps.
Follow the footprints.
Wait, they disappeared.
A miracle happened again.
They're telling you to go find the exit, exit, exit window.
Where is the exit window?
Oh, just keep going.
I'm blind!
No!
No, I don't think you are!
There, there, there, there!
She's just standing there.
She's blocking the exit.
That's cheating.
Uh oh.
I can't open doors.
Oh my god.
She's coming.
Here we go.
She can't open doors either.
She just leaves.
Yeah, she's kinda stupid.
I think you gotta loop around her though.
I think you gotta bait her over here and then loop around.
Right?
I don't think I can loop this way.
Oh, oops.
Oh god.
Oh, oh.
Oh, she looked herself!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Nice.
I'm so smart.
On me, baby.
Dude, look at myself in the mirror.
I'm a vampire.
This is Metal Gear!
Wait, I'm in here.
What do I do in here?
Everything's jammed.
You...
You tricked yourself.
You're now the patient.
Get back.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Punch the mirror!
They're always watching me.
Oh,
I think if I look away, the more I show up.
Yeah, see?
Actually, I lied.
Try and...
Try and leave.
Maybe the door?
Oh, never mind.
Oh, my light's just...
Hello.
Welcome to the no shirt game.
My god, it's a koala.
Why is it like 5 FPS?
It's like 5 FPS for me.
It's the no shirt initiation.
Yeah, right there.
Woo!
No shirts!
No tie!
All service!
Yeah!
Hello?
It's loading.
It's loading to the next level.
Early access, guys.
Early access!
It's the best!
Oh.
Hello?
I hear something.
Maybe try moving.
I am moving.
It's just a black screen for me.
Me too.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, yeah, try.
Oh!
You're back in the house.
I'm back.
No.
Welcome home.
Wait, where's my pills?
I don't think you had any.
Wait.
Oh, no.
You didn't have any pills.
No.
That's not good.
I need my pills.
Oh, no.
Just keep following the...
the vein.
I'm following the veins?
I don't like how I don't have my pills.
I don't like that.
There's these up here.
I don't think you ever had them.
All this way.
Surprise it!
Oh!
I'm jumping!
Get me out!
Oh my god.
Where's the painting?
You can still come down the stairs.
But that's illegal.
Where is he?
Yeah, I was gonna say, where did he go?
Um...
Oh, I have to find the eyes again.
I have to find the eyes again.
But he's chasing you at the same time.
Oh!
I don't know.
We're painting with eyes.
Painting with eyes!
Does it change every time?
Oh!
There's painting with eyes!
You passed one earlier while he was chasing you.
Really?
I was too freaked out.
I think you tried hitting it, but it didn't...
It didn't grab it.
Okay.
I don't know where he went.
He's just gone.
He was upstairs and he went to the left.
It might have been like...
Just, you know...
There's two?!
Oh, that's what it was!
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, fuck.
There's two.
Weeeee!
You, like, slide down the nasty...
...veiny...
Weeeee!
It's like a little ride.
I'm gonna check over here.
I have to find another paint.
No, I'm checking the black veins.
There's none here.
There's one more I'm missing.
No.
Something popped outside.
Something, like, popped outside right here.
Oh, no.
Okay.
This is my only lighter, by the way.
I think you'll be fine.
I don't feel okay.
I don't know where the last painting is.
Oh.
I can't tell if you're zooming around everywhere.
Yeah, these are gamer eyes.
I can register.
Game rush is scanning.
Yeah, I'm scanning.
Oh, yeah, you should turn your little...
Your little game eye thing on.
Just for that moment.
Wait, there's none.
I don't find it.
I literally scan everything.
Did she go...
Go upstairs, yeah.
It's upstairs?
Oh, there's more here.
Yeah.
Oh, the hidden eyes.
No, it's not hidden.
You should stop.
I just never explored.
She just never looked.
Oh, there it is.
AKA hidden.
It's so hidden.
I just...
I'm a little worried that I do only have one lighter left.
And I did...
Who would have thought?
And I did use it this entire time.
Wait, what?
I have to find a key?
Um...
I didn't know where the key is.
Where the fuck is it?
Check the sink.
What do you mean there's a key?
Oh, now the room is so clean.
Oh, they're probably in here.
Oh, there's another eye.
There's another eye.
Wait, how many eyes are there?
Check the door now.
That might have been the key.
Yeah, that might have been the key.
Oh.
Oh, it's another wheelchair.
Another miracle is gonna happen.
Yay!
Back to the hospital.
Back to my safe place.
The hospital.
Yay!
Oh, pizza here.
Okay.
Pizza here.
Yay!
Nothing bad ever happens in the hospital.
Where people die.
Yippee!
It's okay.
I have my friends and family here with me.
You think this is a good operation?
You think they are friends?
They look friend-shaped.
No eyes means I can't disappoint them.
Yay!
Flashbang!
I am a little worried that I don't have any pills.
I am...
That is the most concerning thing for me.
Or lighters.
All I have is two flash bulbs.
I feel like I can trust them.
If they have no eyes, they can't judge me.
Okay, if the only issue is that they'll take my shirt, like, that's fine.
That's okay.
If it's just that shirt, like, that's fine.
That's the sacrifice I'm willing to make.
What are you doing now?
Hello?
I'm back here.
Oh, the door is blocking.
Oh, I'm back in the hospital.
Wait, there's a...
It's dark, man.
Oh, he's pointing.
He's pointing to me.
To the exit.
Not to you.
He's pointing...
He's taking me to the exit.
I knew he was trustworthy.
I knew a guy in all black can be trusted.
All right.
It's like he...
Oh, no, he's just taking me to the exit.
He's telling you...
He's like, this is what...
You don't have your pills.
You didn't take your meds.
It's time to go to the crazy ward.
You think he's trying to say I'm crazy?
No.
I think you're fine.
Yeah, I think I'm okay.
I'll follow the red.
Yeah.
Follow the red paint.
Wait.
The red paint stopped.
Oh, the red paint was just exit.
Maybe I wasn't supposed to follow it.
Wait, unless...
But there's a door that needs a key, so...
Oh!
The fifth floor.
There's math homework again.
You just let him out.
You just let that guy out.
Oh, let's just let the crazy guy out?
Yeah, I think so.
I was just like...
But it's a green button.
Green button means good, right?
He's cured!
We did it, guys!
He's so good!
We cured him!
Come out!
Oh.
You're not supposed to be here!
Oh, my God!
Don't you just let him in...
Fucking...
Just letting him...
Fucking, uh...
Bludgeoned this poor doctor?
What's this?
Oh, it's in our key.
Observation room.
To be observed.
I think it was like back here, right?
Um...
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, you were definitely not paying attention.
Room 5...
I'm not the one playing.
I don't need to pay attention.
Wait, then what's the point of you being here?
Moral support.
Uh-oh, yes.
Oh, so it's forward.
There's nothing back here.
Mm-hmm.
I don't feel morally supported right now.
What?
Wait, go back down the hallway.
No, that's the exit.
No, I think it just said exit.
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, my God, chat.
You were so right, chat.
I was supposed to go down here.
Okay, close the door.
You're gonna regret that.
Who gave this guy a knife?
They have ways of sneaking them in.
How do you know that?
How do you know about the psychiatric ward and sneaking in knives?
I'm a ghost for a reason.
Wait.
You died in the crazy ward?
I don't know.
I might have.
Oh, my God.
I know ghosts that have.
Oh, like who?
Name one ghost that you know.
Name one ghost.
What kind of name are you expecting?
Like...
Spooky...
Spooky McJohnson?
Yes.
My good friend.
I could literally say, there's a ghost named George.
And like, that's just legit.
Oh, why is there tar spots now?
So that you can follow the feet.
Oh, that's true.
That's so true.
It's hand holding you.
Yeah, is that Spooky McJohnson right there?
It could be.
He got confused.
He's like, I don't even know where to go.
He took a little view outside and then went to the showers.
He's looking outside.
He's like, oh, what a lovely view.
I stick my hand in tar.
No way.
In the black hole.
It's like Silent Hill.
No way.
It really is Silent Hill.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I'm just flushing it out.
Oh, I'm unclogging it.
What the fuck is this?
Spooky McJohnson, what did you do?
What did you do, Spooky McJohnson?
Wait.
Is this Dwayne?
Is this Dwayne or Ouroi guided Johnson?
What is this?
Electric box.
Where...
Where was that?
In the toilet.
In the control...
OK, alright.
Was that in the control room?
No, they're showing you where to go.
Hello?
What if these are our footprints now?
Because we got in the nasty toilet.
Alright, go back here, I guess?
They're literally like, hey, by the way, it's in here.
Oh.
What?
Tricked ya!
Okay!
Okay.
I think... I think... Oh my god!
Oh my god, where's his eyes?
The tar man!
Oh my god, the tar man!
It's him!
Wait, is that a death?
Is it?
No, I think he just tranquilized me.
No way.
Yeah.
Because they tranquilized the other guy after he, like, bludgeoned the doctor with his crutch.
They should have not given him crutches.
Why did they give him crutches wheeling him out in a wheelchair?
He deserves to have... Don't give him the... No!
Don't give him the... Okay.
Okay, buddy.
Don't give him the ability to walk if he's just gonna commit crime.
No, maybe, yeah.
Ooh!
What's going on in here?
I'm lost.
Can you see anything?
Yeah, my flashlight started bugging up.
Alright.
I don't like how I'm going downstairs.
I feel like I'm gonna be trapped in here.
Hello?
I guess you don't need to be in...
Yeah, where the hell are you going?
Where am I?
Oh!
It's time.
It's my initiation.
Yeah.
To the no-shirt cult.
Take off your shirt!
Take it off!
Remove your clothes!
Join us!
You will be freed!
You will remove your inhibitions!
Send us to five people!
Take it off!
Woo!
One of us.
Alright.
I'm watching TV.
No.
There's nothing on.
Change the channel!
Fix it!
Fix the TV!
This is not a human right!
Refusing to give me a channel to watch!
Oh.
Where am I?
Are we in dad's parkour room?
Oh my...
You see?
Whoa.
Okay.
I did not say give me more TVs.
There's nothing to watch, though.
Oh.
Whoa.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh.
You think he's...
Hello there.
Again?
Hello.
What am I supposed to do?
Crawl through there.
Now what are you gonna do?
It's outlast...
It's outlast all of a sudden.
Guys, are you gonna go on to the other side?
Yeah.
He's gonna come and get you.
I'm slowly stumbling over.
You have to find something to cut the eye open.
Um.
Oh, I'm so scared.
You seem so frustrated.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm gonna get you.
The way he like stops and like just kind of like contemplates what's going on.
He's like, I got you now.
You're not gonna escape me.
What are you gonna do?
Crawl through that space again and go to the other side?
She's gaming, you guys.
I'm gaming right now.
I'm gaming.
Oh, look at me juking this cripple.
Let me go.
Yeah.
Oh, you're so close.
You're so close.
Whoa.
Okay.
What am I supposed to do?
You just have to find a sharp object to cut the eye.
That's exactly what the game told you.
Wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
He's actually really fast.
He's actually incredibly fast.
Wait, how did he get here already?
You deserve this.
No, I don't.
I'm a good person.
Good people don't say that they're a good person.
Oh, what is he gonna do?
Oh, he's confused.
He's so confused.
He's like, is she gonna go left?
Is she gonna go right?
He's doing his staple.
Where am I gonna go?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Left or right?
You're so confused.
Oh, whoa.
All right.
I need to find the sharp knife.
Okay.
Wait.
He's right there.
Yeah.
Oops.
He's like, actually kind of fast.
Yeah.
So, oh, there it is.
There it is.
Nice.
How do I?
Whoa.
Go back to the eye.
Okay.
All right.
Got the knife.
I'm gonna poke you.
I hear sounds.
Is there a baby in there?
Is it?
And then, like, a baby is born?
Ooh, that looks like it hurts.
Ew.
Oh, I hate this.
I hate the sound.
Pop, it's a boy!
Is that what the inside of the eye looks like?
Yeah.
Oh, like, actually?
Is he back?
Oh, wait.
He's gone.
Yeah, he's gone.
It's like, well, my job here is done.
That was gross.
Pop goes the weasel.
I could live in here.
Like, it's warm.
You are one step away from Vore.
Wait.
Wait, is it?
Is this Vore?
You are actually one step away.
It really, it really was in her bookmarks, you guys.
I just needed to start, like, I need, like, the stomach acid.
Then, uh...
I didn't send it to five people.
This is what happened to me.
It's possessing your mind.
You're starting to like it.
Alright, I'm out here now.
I hate the doors.
Why are the doors so hard to open?
I don't know.
Yeah.
They're, like, so clunky.
And I'm having...
I'm using easy door.
What is easy door?
I don't know.
But it's easier than hard door.
Wait, that's like a setting?
Easy door?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's an actual setting.
Maybe hard door is you have to, like, actually grab the handle or something.
Oh.
You have to, like, aim for it.
It's, like, more immersive.
Like, it makes you feel like you're actually opening a door.
It doesn't, but, you know.
Whatever the game would like to think.
I feel like I don't follow the footsteps because, like...
I came from the footsteps.
Right?
Oh.
Yeah, and then I have to use this on the control room because it's an electricity thing.
Yeah.
Maybe?
No?
Where does this go?
I have this.
I don't know where it...
Yeah, the control...
What is that?
Is there, like, a handle on the...
What is this, anyway?
Is there a handle?
No?
I don't know where I'm supposed to go with this.
I don't know, actually.
Yeah, me too.
Do I actually follow the footsteps?
Maybe they reset.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe they go to a different...
If they go to the window, then...
Yeah, no, it's the same...
It's the same sightseeing.
Yeah.
They, like, look out...
Sightseeing.
Oh, wait, there's more, no?
No, this is where I got the handle.
And this is where I got, like, tranquilized, remember?
Oh, that's right.
Yeah.
Yeah, this was the tranquilizing room.
No, that was...
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Yeah, I got tranquilized right here.
Like, took me to their special room.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
What are you doing here?
Yeah, see?
This is where I got, like, hit.
Through the window.
Yeah.
Through the wall.
There's a guy in there, too.
There's no one here.
That's our room.
It's not our time.
This room was made for me.
Oh, electric room made me!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, is this?
The handle is missing.
Oh.
And then God said, let there be light.
Wait, all the doors might have opened now.
Now what do I do?
Was there something that couldn't be opened because of the power?
I don't remember.
Not being on?
Is it room 13?
This room?
No?
Daddy's mad.
Lucy?
Daddy doesn't know where to go!
I don't like this.
Oh, maybe this door is open now?
No?
What the fuck?
Just maybe keep following the hallway.
Hello?
I think all of these are just whatever.
Oh, the elevator!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
It was the elevator.
All right.
Yippee!
We're figuring it out.
We're so smart.
I know.
Wow.
All on our own.
No help whatsoever.
No help.
Oh, am I gonna be back in my house?
Don't take me back to the house.
I don't have pills.
Let me stay in the hospital.
Oh.
With all the pills.
This is fancy.
Oh, this is a VIP.
This is where people who have insurance go to.
This is the insurance ward.
I'm in a private hospital right now.
With a private wing.
Yeah.
Oh, I have to go this way.
Wait, this is so much fancier.
Is this what privilege gets you?
Wow.
Like everything is fresh and clean.
Yeah, there's like plants everywhere.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh my God.
They get their own water.
Oh, okay.
They get their own water cooler.
Five FPS.
Oh, good news.
Oh, look.
You can walk now.
I don't think so.
I don't think he's awake, doctor.
I don't think he's like...
Oh, no, no, no.
He's moving his hands.
You see that little twitch there?
Wait, the doctor doesn't have a nose.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
Oh, he's faceless.
Yeah.
Wait, I can be closer.
Oh.
Oh, I was too close.
The doctor was Voldemort this whole time?
Look, he needed a new career change.
Okay?
He's like, you can go home.
Look, he had...
Look, he got...
Ever since he got kicked out of the Wizarding World, he had to find a new job.
Oh, no.
He locked me up.
Wait, I'm not the crazy one.
Sit in the chair.
No?
They won't let me.
It's because I can walk.
They don't let walkers on the chair.
Is there something on the desk where the light is?
I'm checking the TV.
What?
Let's check the drawers?
No, I can't open it.
What's that sound?
Wait, the drawer's where the lamp is?
The fuck?
Can't open those either?
Put my flashlight on the other pocket.
Hello?
Nurse?
Someone said try to move the shelf.
Can you move it?
Oh!
There's like the scrapes!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
This game is too smart for streamers.
This...
No, we're so smart.
We figured it out.
Guys, streamers don't look down.
We all know that.
Everybody knows gamers don't look up.
Or down.
Or behind.
We just look forward.
Yeah.
Or gas, gas, gas, gas.
Exactly.
Alright, I can fit that.
Okay, I can't.
Just because I had one grape, I can't fit the hole.
Not the single grape.
The single grape that expanded me a little bit.
One centimeter wide.
Down I go.
Wait, take the flashlight.
Why do I...
Yeah, take the flashlight.
Yeah, what the fuck?
Take the flashlight.
What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with me?
Take the fucking flashlight.
Do it!
Oh my god!
I can use...
I have two hands!
Put it in your mouth!
Oh, you're back home?
Oh, I'm back home.
No flashlights allowed in the house.
Daddy's rules.
Daddy said no flashlight.
Wait.
Actually, I don't think you're back home.
I don't think this is home.
Oh!
Oh, hi.
Hello?
He's observing us!
I like the...
The subtitle.
Who's Raka?
Who's they?
That's him!
That's the guy that's been chasing us and crutches!
What do you mean?
I know!
But like, who is that in the story?
I'm on to you?
Who's that guy?
Who sent you?
Oh.
What?
Do you think he's okay?
Are those happy screams?
You can probably leave now.
No, wait.
I want to hear him scream a little longer.
It's gonna loop eventually.
Is it?
He can't scream forever.
Oh, see?
Look.
He got rapture.
He drank the Red Bull!
Yay!
He drank the cooling!
He got wings!
Oh.
Whoa.
Poke the eyeball.
Poke.
One last...
One last eyeball for the ride.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's like...
You know, like there's like...
Oh, what the fuck?
No, this one's ours.
Oh, this is probably...
Yeah!
We even completed a chapter!
We did it!
This chapter was a lot less scary.
It was really fast.
Yeah, this one was a...
It was a nice and easy chapter.
I like that.
Prison.
And silenced.
Wait, I don't have lighters anymore.
Wait, what happened to my lighter?
Wait a minute.
You know what?
That's for future Doki to worry about.
So true.
That is future Doki's problem.
Wait, they closed all the door.
Where are we?
Back home?
I can't see anything.
Oh, you can hide.
Yes.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
I don't like how I have no items whatsoever.
What's so...
They stole from you.
They stole my lady.
Those freaks.
Stupid ghost.
That's why you guys don't deserve rights.
What?
You don't even know.
I got...
If you're dead, what type of rights do you need when you're dead?
Why wouldn't we have rights?
Because you're dead.
Wait, you're saying all ghosts are the same?
Like all ghosts are gonna steal your lighters?
Yes.
I know you have a stash of lighters.
I didn't steal it.
Yeah, because someone...
Another ghost already stole it.
I bought all my lighters.
I didn't steal these from people.
That's what they say.
Yeah, that's right.
I bought it.
Speak to the ghost cops.
Where's my eyeball?
Only one chocolate!
Guys, I'm not gonna do the next chapter right now.
I don't have anything and I don't...
The only thing I have is a camera.
Beep, beep.
Snap.
That goes into my cringe compilation.
And then there's my personal confessional.
Yeah.
You are forgiven.
Did you get that fixed?
No, I need to go to...
I need to go to like a store to buy a new one.
So I can be like, You are forgiven for your crimes.
Next week, we finish it?
Wait, someone said storage replenishes items.
I think there's an actual storage.
Someone said maybe in the...
Wait, downstairs?
There's a storage?
Okay, that's for future Doki.
Don't worry about it.
I'm not going to...
Yeah, everybody remind us next time.
Yeah, remind us next time that there is an extra storage for more lighters and pills for us.
Remember.
Alright, so...
Yippee!
We did two chapters!
One chapter left, guys!
One chapter left!
Actually, I think this one was definitely a lot less scary.
Because it was like more linear and we're not in the house at all, which was great.
Like, I don't have to worry about resource management.
No, the fact that we didn't have to worry about items was really nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That one...
This one was so fucking stressful.
It was so lit up.
Yeah.
You got the worst one out of the way.
I think this other...
I think this chapter...
You have to be inside, though.
I'm pretty sure.
This chapter...
Yeah, it's like in the house.
I think this is the only chapter that's not in the house, too.
Oh.
Oh, people are saying the last chapter is terrifying.
Maybe I should have kept this one as the last one.
You were like, I'm doing the easy one and you chose it so quickly.
I just assumed...
Supposedly the second chapter is the scariest.
I assumed that like...
Okay, because I saw crutches.
So I was like, okay.
It's obviously that Ghost isn't going to chase...
Like, it's not going to be that fast.
Because he's like on a crutch, you know?
So like, he's going to be hobbling a lot.
You should have saved it for the last line.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, I...
Look, past Doki was not thinking straight.
Okay, past Doki was like...
He can't catch me if he can't walk.
You know, like...
How am I going to die to a guy who can't walk?
Wait, people are saying there's four chapters.
No, there's three chapters.
There's only three bowls here.
Yeah, there's three bowls.
We know there's three...
If there's three bowls, there's three chapters.
Right?
Right, guys?
I think there's three and then a finale.
There's a finale?
No.
That doesn't sound right.
The moment I see end credits, it's over.
Yeah.
We don't make the rules, guys.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
I said finish the game.
And when you finish the game, the end credits show up.
So...
Sounds legit to me.
Yeah, yeah.
Anything past that is new game plus.
Yeah, new NG plus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't say NG plus playthrough.
I said...
I said finish the game.
And that's where the end credits start.
What if the next one isn't so bad?
Then we could do it.
What?
The fourth chapter?
That doesn't exist?
The fourth chapter that doesn't exist, guys?
Because there's only three chapters?
Only three.
Yeah, okay.
Wait.
All chapters before the...
When was the last update when they added the fourth chapter?
Was it before or after the charity?
All chapters before the game updated in 2020.
2020?
Wait.
I don't know.
I don't know when this game...
I know when the game first came out, there was three chapters.
And then they added the fourth chapter later.
Later on.
So whenever the game first came out...
Oh, no.
Actually, when the game first came out, there was only one chapter.
They just kept adding because it was early access.
Because Lucy was the very first chapter they added.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
And then they progressively just added more and more chapters in the end.
And I'm so glad this one was a short one.
I'm trying to see if there's, like, updates on Steam, but I don't see any.
Well, the game came... finished, like, a long time ago.
I can't believe this is the only game they made, though.
I thought they would make more after, like, how successful it was.
Right?
Yeah, like, everybody talked... like, everybody... it's, like, one of the... I am not... What do you mean charity fraud?
I'm literally playing the game.
I can't commit fraud if the game is still being played.
I can't... you can call me a fraud in five years, okay?
In five years?
In five years when I never complete the playthrough.
If the game is progressively getting played every couple of years, then it's not a fraud.
It's not...
I'm just... One chapter a year, everybody.
What if I make a... what if I make a... like, for the last chapter, I make a waiting room, but set it to, like, 2027 or something.
Oh, my God.
We schedule... we schedule...
It's just always... it's always looming on your channel.
On my channel?
Like, final chapter, 2027.
Everybody, look forward to it!
April 17th, 4 p.m.
PSD.
Woo!
Oh, yeah.
So it's not fraud because the waiting room's there.
The waiting room...
Um...
What if we do that?
What if we actually...
I mean, are you down?
The final chapter?
We set it up to 2026 or seven?
And then it just...
What if...
Stays in the... stays on my channel for two... one to two years?
You should have it at least one year.
Or, like, put it for one year.
Oh, okay.
Our anniversary of this playthrough.
All right.
The final...
Or you have it so that...
People can knock the time down somehow.
The knock the time down?
How do they knock it?
Yeah, like, you have it set for a year and then somehow...
They have to...
It's like, we have, like, missions and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, objectives and achievements and be like, If you get this and you complete this mission, I'll take 10 days off of it.
It's like, their own, like...
There's like...
What are those, like...
Those, like, games that people do online?
It's like...
What is it called?
Like, uh...
Uh...
Oh, my God.
Like, there's, like, little puzzles and stuff.
They do.
To unlock more stuff.
I don't think people like our ideas.
ARG!
We make this an ARG.
They're sending a bunch of angry emojis.
No.
Like, we make it...
We make it an ARG.
And then, like, as they complete the ARG, we knock more time off of the...
Off of it.
All right.
No gotcha for two.
It's not gotcha.
You just gotta complete our quest.
To unlock the final chapter.
Look at...
I don't think...
Okay, fine.
We'll do chapter four.
No.
We were going to.
We were...
How bad they are.
It'll be fun.
The ARG will be fun, guys.
The ARG...
We'll make, like, mazes...
And puzzles.
And they have to, like, scan this QR code to complete this puzzle.
It's like a geocache.
We'll hide something somewhere.
Yeah.
We'll hide someone.
Something.
We'll pay someone to hide something.
A little treasure chest in, like, the middle of the forest.
And then, like, if you find it and scan that QR code, it reduces the timeline by a month or something.
Like...
It gives you...
The QR code will give you the password to Doki's YouTube channel so that you can manually go and...
Watch the timeline by yourself.
You access my channel.
Yeah.
Give access.
Change it.
Look.
We said chapter four.
It'll be...
It'll be locked next year.
We didn't say chapter three.
Okay?
We're just planning ahead.
We're...
Yeah.
You can start the stream yourself.
You can be like, okay, Doki, play the game.
You can start the stream.
Yeah.
Yo, I'm down.
Let's make an ARG for the...
Oh, my God.
This is your charity thing.
I am not affiliated, everybody.
I am just here for moral support.
So, please direct all your complaints and criticisms to Doki Bird channel.
Yeah, but the majority of the ideas came from...
She was the one that came up with the geocache.
I might make it.
She came up with the geocache idea.
It's like that...
It's like that Gravity Falls shit where they hid Bill Cypher in the middle of the fucking forest.
Oh, yeah!
I just hid...
I just hide, like, a miniature replica of me and...
I don't think anybody is going to do this.
Wait, they waited a year for you to play this from the charity stream?
Yeah, because the charity was last year.
So, it's already been a year?
Yeah, so then they...
Okay, it's one chapter.
I'm subbing, I'm remembering until April 2020.
Until April 2020.
The threats are real.
I'll come back to your channel when you play the fourth chapter.
What do you mean?
It'll be a fun experience!
Like, we're uniting our fans on a little treasure hunt.
Don't you guys like treasure hunts?
And the reward is just me streaming chapter four.
We've already waited, though!
Yeah, but it's chapter four!
Chapter three...
We're doing chapter three next week!
What?
Premeditated anger.
Pre...
They're getting ready to be angry.
It'll be fun, guys!
No, we got through the last...
We got through this one so easily.
I think we can do the last two easy.
Yeah, yeah, I think so, too.
But it's more about...
It's...
No!
We don't...
We don't wanna play this treasure hunt.
Everyone, it is so mad!
Jokey, you have to go outside.
I'm not...
I can pay someone to hide it!
I can literally...
I just, like, hide it in Alaska or something.
Like, it's buried in the snow in Alaska.
And there's, like, a lot of people have to...
Counter offer.
We do that, but it's with Mint forcing you to play her copy of P.T.
Oh, yeah.
Do you wanna play P.T.?
Oh, my goodness.
I have to fly over for that.
Yeah?
You're, like, the only one with a physical copy of P.T.
P.T.
How much is the...
Are those, anyway?
Like, the play...
Like, the PlayStation that houses a P.T.
game?
I have no idea, because I just kept mine.
I feel like they'd be...
It's, like, those people that sell their iPhone with a copy of Flappy Bird.
Flappy Bird?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
P.T.
eBay.
I'm gonna check.
Oh, yeah, check, check, check.
PS4 with P.T.
on it.
Oh, it's, like, $600.
How much is, like, a normal PS4 nowadays?
Oh, wait, Canadian, though.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
How much...
Play...
PS4...
PS4, eBay.
I feel like I should pause this game.
I don't know if I'm slowly going crazy just standing in the confessional room.
Oh, look, you're surrounded.
Oh.
It's, like, $200 Canadian for a normal...
Like, $150.
Oh, it's $150 for a normal PS4.
So, like, your copy of P.T.
is literally $500.
Holy cow.
But if you wait longer, if you wait longer, the value goes up.
I'm not...
Well, yeah, I mean, yeah.
You think about it.
Cool.
Wait, PS4 with P.T.
I wanna see what it is on my end.
Oh, yeah, cuz you get, like, the actual non-Monopoly money.
I see one $328.
I like this.
PlayStation 4, PS4 with playable trailer P.T.
Silent Hill demo installed.
Rare.
It has 59 watchers.
Oh, my God.
They're hoping the prices will drop, but it'll never drop.
There's one with, like...
They're seeking it out.
Why is this one a thousand dollars?
What the fuck?
What?
Why is that one so expensive?
I'm not seeing...
I'm only seeing the one.
Oh, wait.
Oh, this one is $864.
Yeah.
Like, why is it so expensive?
Oh, cuz it's a rare white, like, version of the PS4.
But I can get an illegal version where it's just a USB drive.
I just buy...
Wait, I can just literally buy the USB drive and just plug it into my PS4.
Uh, I mean, yeah?
Yeah.
That's like...
So you play it.
No.
That's not part of charity.
What?
Then you gotta play chapter four, baby.
Okay.
It has been decided.
Well, chapter three is the scary one, apparently.
So...
Or, like, the...
Or second chapter.
Yeah, yeah.
The second chapter is apparently the most scary one.
So, like, the...
So, the moment I get the grandma chapter out of the way...
Chapter four can't be that bad, I assume.
Let's see how...
Let's see how long it is.
The last chapter.
The last chapter?
Well, we'll find out next week how long it will be.
Yeah.
No, no.
The chapter four, I mean.
Oh, chapter four?
Yeah.
Let's see.
How long is it?
I still think doing an AIG would be fucking funny.
Oh.
Yeah, oh.
It's long.
Oh, how long?
Wait, okay.
Someone...
This is from a couple years ago, but they're like...
But actually, this is keeping on track with our record.
They said, this is our person...
This is my personal experience on a scale of one to five.
One being shortest.
Five being longest to complete.
Uh-huh.
Three...
Shortest was the one we just did.
Uh-huh.
Second shortest is Lucy.
Third shortest...
Second to longest is the next one, Dolores.
And then the end chapter is a little shorter than Dolores.
Uh...
You mean it's longer than Lucy?
Um...
Everyone's saying the grandma chapter is the scariest, too.
Oh, wait.
Someone also said, it will depend on which one you do first, as you generally need to explore the house and unlock some areas.
I did Dolores first, and it was longest by far.
But I think that was because I had a bit of exploring to do before getting to the core of the chapter.
Oh, so you had to unlock certain areas, too.
Maybe.
So we had to like...
Well, I mean, like, we spent the second chapter...
This chapter, like, in the hospital.
I don't think we unlocked...
We didn't unlock anything in the last chapter.
No.
So I feel like...
I feel like...
But people are saying this next one is gonna be long.
Her plot isn't linear like the other two.
What do you mean linear?
Like, Lucy wasn't that linear, was it?
Lucy was not linear.
No, I have to explore a lot.
I was like, where the fuck am I?
Okay.
Oh, chapter four.
Do you want me to just tell you?
What?
Tell me what.
You have to get the VHS tapes that you've been collecting.
Yeah?
You have to get them for the last chapter.
What?
Yeah.
I have to actually...
What?
You've been getting them regardless.
You just got two of them.
You already have two of them.
Yes, you do.
How much...
How many tapes are there?
I don't know.
How many?
Maybe three, I guess?
What do you mean?
What do you mean I felt...
You mean I was supposed to pick things up?
You have them in your inventory right now!
You have them!
But like, how many are there?
Oh, there's seven tapes?
Oh.
I hope I'm getting the last five at Dolores.
I hope the last five is with Dolores.
Oh, no.
Oh.
So, like, about that ARG that we're doing.
With the last chapter.
Oh.
About that ARG, man.
This is your decision.
I...
I have no say.
I do not want the people angry at me.
About making little missions for them to chop down the time.
Every mission is a...
Is a tape found.
Yeah.
Every mission you complete in this ARG, we find another tape.
We...
We just...
It just leads you to, like, a video.
You complete the mission.
A QR code shows up and you scan the QR code.
And it leads you to a video recording of me finding that tape.
That means you would have to...
Oh, my God.
The chat is red again.
You're scaring me.
I don't like this evil.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Someone said you could get a save file with all the tapes.
What?
Wait, how?
I copy a save file and move it to the game.
And then I just start the game with all the...
With all the tapes.
Like, hey guys, I just did this all off stream.
Because I knew it would be so tedious to do it on stream for you guys.
So...
Well, you just gave away your evil plan.
Yeah, but they didn't want to know.
You didn't want to know.
It was just a joke.
It was just imagination, you know?
That's just...
JK!
Teehee!
What if like, mint collects all...
I'll give her my save file.
Oh my god!
I'm not...
I did not...
I did not collect this stuff for charity!
This is not...
I...
I give her my save file.
If you both need this, I'm not...
I'm not going to...
I am not going to be back next week.
You can guarantee that.
I know!
It's the scariest chapter, man!
You can't do this!
I was there for the entire play for a mortary assistant.
I was there for all the endings!
No, no, no!
We only...
I was there for all the endings, man!
You had to be there for...
This is my...
I'm cashing in my IOU.
This is...
This is not my charity stream!
Oh, you...
Yours wasn't even doing it for charity!
You did it for fun!
Yeah!
I have no stakes!
You can't hold me!
You can't hold this against me!
That is...
Min hates charity, too!
What?!
She hates charity!
She won't do it out of the goodness of her own heart, because there's no good in that...
There's a reason why she didn't go to heaven and is stuck in the ghost purgatory.
And you think about it.
The only reason...
I did go to heaven!
I just got kicked out!
The only reason ghosts become ghosts is if they have unfinished business.
It's a charity stream!
Yeah, it's a charity stream!
The moment you complete this, you can't go back to heaven!
Don't...
Don't make me come back!
I mean, you could go downstairs if you want!
Wait, so that means if we finish the game, then I...
You go to hell!
I go to the light!
Yeah, go to the red light, Min!
The red light!
It's calling for you!
It feels so warm!
I feel...
Warmly!
Yeah, yeah!
You don't have to feel cold anymore!
You know?
Yeah!
Oh wait, what if you get, like, your new outfit is just...
You go to hell!
That's your new outfit!
This is my hell-fit!
I'm literally this on fire!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
If you ever get a goth, mental outfit, it's just you in hell!
I do have a goth outfit.
Oh!
Yeah, but you're still a ghost.
You're still a ghost, though.
So does it really count?
Oh my god, I like how you wear an RGB.
You wear an RGB there for a sec.
Yeah.
Wait, my ears don't match my head anymore.
No, you're like those cats with like...
Like those like, the genetic defects where...
Ah!
Is that actually the proper way to say it?
Like genetic defects?
And then like there's like mutations where they're partially a different cat breed.
Calico?
No, I don't know.
There's like...
There's like a thing where like some dogs and cats, or like some animals, they can like have like partial cat breeds or something.
So like half the cat is like a different breed.
Oh!
What?
That's weird.
Yeah, no, I've seen like... Wait, let me see if I...
Camaro?
No, no, it's like... Okay.
Um...
Different cats.
Split cat breeds.
I remember reading about it.
Because it happens with dogs, too.
Yeah, it's like... Oh yeah, that's how you get like labradoodles and things like that.
Like this.
Like, you know, someone...
They can be a black cat and a tabby cat at the same time.
Oh!
Whoa!
That's... This looks AI generated.
No, it's... No, it's called... Oh wait, it's... It is a chimera cat.
Yeah.
Yeah, the chimera... It's a chimera cat.
The... Meet Narnia.
The rare chimera cat that has a perfectly split face.
They're so cute!
Yeah, so you can get like... You can split them up.
So you can like... One is like a tabby and one is the...
Uh... One is like a black cat.
And they can have different eye colors, too.
I know it happens in dogs, too.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, it is called a chimera cat.
It is chimera.
Whoa!
Oh, that's cool.
I want a chimera cat.
Cool.
Yeah, you look like... You look like a chimera cat right there with your white and black ears.
I am.
Yeah, I'm just different species.
Yeah, one is in heaven, the other is in hell.
It's like the angel and the devil on your shoulder.
I can be both.
This is a picture for you.
I could be your angle, or I could be your devil.
This is... I feel like we're sort of the angel and devil.
But then we're like two devils instead.
Yeah, we're just two devils.
One gives you an even worse-tier option.
Yeah, one gives you a bad option, one gives you the worst option.
One will be like, jump, come on, take the jump.
And then I'll be like, do a flip while you jump.
Yeah, do a flip while you jump.
It'll be so cool.
And look how cute they are.
Yeah, I like the fact that different eye colors too.
Yeah.
That's really cute.
But yeah, alright guys.
I guess we'll see you at chapter 3 next week.
Same time, same...
Wait, actually I need to check my calendar.
Yeah, me too.
I need to check my calendar.
I think I have a sponsor at like at the 24th.
So most likely whenever...
I think my day's busiest is Thursday and Friday.
So...
Hello, dad.
He's hungry.
He's already ate.
He can't be hungry.
I already fed him.
You're not allowed to be hungry.
No hungry for you.
Can you hear me?
Ruff, ruff, ruff, ruff, ruff.
Speak, speak, speak, speak.
No, I'm wearing headphones, you fucking idiot.
What do you mean, can he hear me?
If I'm loud enough, if I'm loud enough, he'll hear me.
Mine is an ear-covered headphone.
I'm not wearing open ear.
Can he hear me?
Dad!
Can you hear me?
Please respond to me!
You what?
I want him to speak!
Can you make him speak?
No, he only speaks if I have food.
He doesn't care about anything.
I can pretend to have food.
Wait, let me see my vitamins.
Yeah.
Hello, you want vitamins?
Hello?
Yeah, it's too chill.
All right, there you go.
I have, like, toast.
I tried to...
I ordered this from this new place that...
You know those of those Korean sandwiches?
Have you had one of those?
Where it's, like, one giant slice of toast...
And then they put, like, eggs and stuff on it as the toppings?
No, I don't think so.
It is so hard to eat.
Like, because it's, like, fucking wide as fuck.
And then, like...
Come on, you want this?
You want this?
You won't get it until you bark.
Now you're just teasing him.
Yeah, but that's the only way he'll bark.
If I, like, don't get him through it.
Really?
He doesn't bark if you, like, bark at him?
Or if he's a spear?
No, I know.
He doesn't.
He doesn't care.
You want this?
I'm just gonna hold it, like, just above him.
I wanna hear him.
Like, he'll bark eventually if I just hold it just above him.
Because he'll get frustrated that I'm not giving him food.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's just there!
Yeah, I just need to make him mad.
Okay.
Yeah, don't worry.
As long as...
Look, Mint wanted me to make him mad.
Like, so it's not my fault.
She's the one that...
She's the one that wants to make him mad.
Yeah, I'm torturing you, Dad.
Sorry.
Alright, wait.
It's gonna be like, Daddy's angry.
Lucy.
Daddy's angry.
I demand the food.
I demand the bread.
So it looks like...
Basically, it looks like this.
Oh!
Yeah, but it's like...
Oh, it looks good.
It is like...
It depends on, like, where you order.
But it's so fucking hard to eat, though.
Because it's just, like...
It's just so wide.
And, like, my mouth does not fit.
Yeah, it looks like it would be difficult.
Yeah, so, like, the toppings were, like, spilling out.
I'll show it to chat.
The toppings were, like, spilling out and everything.
So I was, like, having the most difficult time trying to eat this.
Alright.
Come on.
Bark.
I'll put this...
Yum yum yum.
Bark, come on.
Are you angry yet?
Are you mad?
He's not mad.
He's just looking at me.
He's, like...
Okay, next time.
Next time, we'll get a...
Alright, next time, we'll get in the bark.
Yeah.
Next time, I'll, like, make sure to, like...
Okay, my dog, he, like, knows his schedule and everything.
So he knows exactly...
So, when I'm doing, like, a 12-30 stream, and I stream a little too long, he, like, walks over and be, like, where's my food?
He literally, like, reminds me to, like, feed him.
And then he knows when I end stream.
Yeah, he's hungry.
He knows when I end stream, too.
And then, like, when I'm, like, about to end stream, he, like, starts barking.
He's, like, is it feeding time?
Or, like, he also reminds me for, like, if I need to refill his water as well.
Because I have those automatic...
Yeah, because he's thirsty!
Automatic water dispensers.
So the moment the water is empty, he, like, walks over and be, like, Water now!
Water!
Water is empty!
He's so smart.
Yeah, yeah.
He, like, wakes me up, too.
He's, like, it's feeding time!
You know?
Oh, yeah.
Because I know, like, cats do that.
Cats will make sure you don't breathe.
Like, they sit on you, right?
Oh, it depends on the cat.
No, my cat, he just scratches the door until I wake up.
And then he runs away when I get him to...
He'll just scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch.
Food.
Yeah, yeah, he's like, food now.
Food now.
Or if he's in my bed and I'm sleeping and my hand is by my head, he'll eat my fingers.
What?
He'll eat your fingers?
Yeah, he'll bite my fingers trying to get me to...
I don't know if he's trying to eat me or if he's trying to...
He's trying to bore you?
I'm done.
I'm leaving.
I'm leaving this stream.
See you next week.
You know, like, if you die and, like, and your cat is, like, like, I heard that, like, uh, your pets will eat you if you're dead.
Yeah, I heard that, too.
Because it's just free food to them.
I would let them.
I mean, I don't want them to starve, you know?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, because, like, I live alone.
Like, who's going to feed my dog?
Don't think about it.
That's so sad.
Don't think about that.
So, like, so, you know, I want my dog to be able to feed him, so I give consent.
This is the stream where, like, if a news article publishes an article where my dog eats my face after, like...
It's consensual.
I gave him permission.
He's not a bad dog.
He was just trying to survive.
I mean, if you're dead, who cares?
Yeah, who cares?
As long as I'm...
I mean, I'm a ghost already, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get to be one with my dog, that's fine.
I don't think many...
I don't think...
I think you might want to...
Wait, wait, okay, wait.
I live on through my dog.
I live on through him.
I'm going to leave you and let you digest that with your chat.
And...
Yeah.
You have fun.
You know what I said?
You let your cat eat you, too.
Yeah, but I did not say that.
I was going to become one with my cat.
Don't you want your cat to live on through...
Don't you want to live on through your cat?
Bye, dookie!
Alright, I'll see you next week, man.
See you next week!
Bye, bye!
Alright, everybody.
I'm glad that chapter was easier.
Because...
This game's fucked up.
This game.
But...
I'm also not happy...
That I...
Left the hardest chapter for last.
Because chapter 3 is the last chapter, as we all know.
So, I guess...
I'll see you guys next week for chapter 3 for the...
I'm like...
Oh my god, of course it's the grandma chapter, too.
So...
Of course the grandma chapter is going to be the hardest.
Like, the elderly is so scary.
Like, they don't...
They have, like, the...
The...
Like, you know, the old people's strength.
Where they don't know how strong they are because they're old.
Because they can't, like, limit test anymore.
So, like, it's either...
It's either, like, they're super strong or they're weak as hell.
Uh...
No, of course...
Yeah!
Those people are...
Like, the elderly are a little scary.
Because, like, they don't know their own strength.
Like...
So...
So I'm a little...
I'm a little scared about chapter 3.
And I read that it also has the hardest puzzles.
I feel like we sort of already struggled enough in the Lucy chapter.
For puzzles.
Like, we...
Min and I, we both share, like, one singular brain cell.
And I think Min has, like, 0.9 of that.
She has...
She has 0.9 of that singular brain cell.
So it's gonna be rough.
Lucy's chapter was more so because, like...
I was being chased by two things in Lucy's chapter.
Because it was, like, the fucking ghost.
And then, like, there was Lucy and her, like, little demon friend.
So, like, I feel like that's what made it really hard.
Because she was...
What?
What does that say?
It's, like, behind her...
What did she write there?
I hate the guy...
The item is, like, behind her hair.
Like...
I did not know her forehead was that big, guys.
If you, like, lift her...
Um...
There's something wrong with her.
If you lift up her forehead...
That her...
Her...
Her bangs...
Like...
Like, you can find the...
If you lift her bangs up...
You'll find the entire novel of Moby Dick underneath there.
That's written down there.
Um...
Push...
Yeah, you push back her bangs.
It's an entire novelization of Moby Dick.
Oh, my God!
I can have ad space on there.
Mint, get a toggle where you can lift up your bangs...
So I can advertise something beneath your bangs.
Like, I can put...
I can...
Let me put my gamer subcode underneath your bangs.
I'll buy ads.
I'll pay you for ad space.
If you have that.
Oh, you...
She's missing out on the barks!
He's barking now.
He's frustrated.
You wanted more food.
Yeah.
Oh, my God!
That's where one of the ARG is!
That's...
One of the...
Have a QR code underneath her bangs.
Just lift it up so you can scan the QR code.
Oh, my God!
I'm...
I'm cooking right now.
I'm actually cooking with some great ideas.
Like, imagine...
You lift it up and there's a QR code.
Where will it lead you?
It'll lead you to an ARG.
Let me buy ad space on your head.
Honestly, that is like...
That should be the next like...
I'm cooking up like ways for sponsors to use VTubers for advertisement.
You can just buy ad space on our body.
Like, you know how like...
You know how like flesh...
Flesh Tubers...
They like sit on...
Like they're...
They have like those like cameras and everything.
And they're in their background.
It's like ad space and stuff.
Like, you know, they put like the...
The Red Bull fridge and everything.
The Red Bull fridge.
The gaming chair.
What they're advertising.
And then the background is like all their advertisements and stuff.
So like for us, you can literally just...
We're like a NASCAR.
Oh my god!
You can NASCAR us!
We can just buy ad space on us.
And then we just have like...
We have like a Red Bull stick...
Like we have like a picture of a Red Bull...
On our face.
Like a Red Bull tattoo on our cheeks or something.
On our face cheeks.
And like a Formula One race car.
Yeah.
Put on some temporary tattoo.
Ka-chow.
We gotta ka-chow it up.
Yeah.
I'm cooking.
I'm like...
I'm revolutionizing VTuber ad space.
How much are you charging ad space?
We're like a New York billboard.
We'll be your New York billboard out in Times Square.
Hooter tattoo.
When Hooters went bankrupt!
Guys.
Rest in peace Hooters.
Who would've thought...
Girls...
Hot ladies serving you chicken wings...
Hot wings was not the right business move.
Who would've thought...
Society is crumbling now, guys.
We are at a point where Hooters is now going bankrupt.
Like, what else...
What do we have now?
What...
They had a good run.
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Next week, we will do...
Chapter 3.
And then Chapter 4 will be ARG.
I'll think about what the fate of Chapter 4...
I'll decide what happens to Chapter 4...
When we finish Chapter 3, guys.
Hey!
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around...
To get that blood flowing.
And if you still for me...
Head to bed.
Because...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.